bien mes mes chers
collègues nous recevons ce matin
monsieur aéen Rousseau ministre de la
santé et de la prévention avec un sujet
important le projet de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 j'indique à
tout le monde que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible à la demande voilà
donc monsieur le ministre on va très
vite rentrer dans le vif du sujet on va
bien entendu commencer par un propos de
votre part pour nous présenter les
grands enjeux du volet santé du pfss
mais également ger la la dimension
budgétaire financière de la branche
maladie voilà puis ensuite très
naturellement nous demanderons à nos
rapporteurs à la fois madame douanau
rapporteur général et Madame Ambert
rapporteur de la branche de vous
solliciter pour un certain nombre de
questions puis nous ouvrirons le débat à
l'ensemble des commissaires ici présents
voilà donc ce que je vous propose
monsieur le ministre tout de suite je
vous donne la
parole merci beaucoup je vous prie de
m'excuser de de mon retard nous avons
défoncé la porte dans l'entrée du du
Sénat avec ma voiture
euh mais je vous rassure le mur du Sénat
se porte bien mieux que la voiture donc
voilà non je veux toutes mes
excuses
comment c'est une métaphore voilà donc
donc comment bah oui je
sais je sais voilà monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur général madame la
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs euh je vous remercie pour
votre invitation évidemment à laquelle
je suis heureux de de répondre dans dans
cette période qui est chargée pour nous
tous et et et on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler à plusieurs reprises lors du
débat du débat d'avantiè et d'hier et je
vous j'en profite évidemment pour vous
remercier
euh de la
qualité des débats euh et renouveler mes
mes mes mes excuses pour le caractère
acrobatique par moment de certains euh
de l'examen de certains amendements
euh voilà et et et c'est vrai que avant
de parler du du PLFSS et on le verra
sans doute dans le dans l'échange que
nous aurons il est vrai qu'il y a
certains sujets qui qui qui s'articule
avec la proposition de loi que que vous
avez
examiné hier mais
aussi je suis à votre disposition pour
évoquer aussi la question de la
négociation conventionnelle avec les
médecins libéraux
euh ce sont trois leviers de
transformation qui forment un tout
cohérent euh enfin plus exactement qui
doivent former un tout cohérent et
j'espère qu'il le qu'ils le formeront
euh ce matin donc nous concentrons sur
le le P
PLFSS et je l'ai
rappelé à monsieur le Président à Madame
à mesdames les rapporteurs général et
les rapporteurs pour vous dire que d'une
certaine manière le le le débat le débat
notamment à la à la condition des
affairesverrouill votreone voilà coup le
son voilà donc c'est jamais est bon
quand l'iPhone se met à parler seul euh
parce qu'il peut se mettre à lire les
textos et donc moi ça m'est arrivé une
fois et j'en ai un souvenir ému
donc donc
euh je vais y arriver
euh je je le dis aussi parce que les
conditions d'examen à l'Assemblée mais
mais mais mais qui ne sont pas que qui
je ne renvoie la faute sur personne
euh font que il y a eu un assez bon
débat de ce qui m'a été rapporté puisque
évidemment je je n'y assistais pas enfin
on a eu un bon débat d'audition à la
commission il y a eu 1000 amendements
adopté en commission et puis après la
commission a rejeté le texte ce qui fait
paradoxalement que y compris des points
sur lesquels il y avait des
améliorations indéiables et parce queun
texte il est forcément
perfectible n'ont pas été n'ont pas été
ces améliorations au cœur du débat donc
moi je
je dans le temps qui est le nôtre dans
le délai qui est le nôtre mais je vous
je vous
redis ma disponibilité avec je l'espère
un tout petit peu plus d'anticipation
euh que que que sur que sur la la PPL
Valtou et donc on aura l'occasion
d'échanger sur un très grand nombre de
mesures qu'ell soit dans le texte
initial ou qu'elle soit dans dans dans
le texte euh apporté par les députés ou
par le gouvernement à l'Assemblée
nationale
euh avant de de d'évoquer les les
mesures précises et en essayant d'être
le plus rapide possible et je voulais
rappeler un contexte vous que vous
connaissez mais mais qui est qui qui est
quand même un contexte essentiel et qui
est au fond qui soutend un peu le le le
la construction du PLFSS que je que je
souhaite défendre on a eu trois exercice
voire quatre qui ont porté des moyens
inédits pour protéger notre
pays face à la crise du covid puis face
à
l'inflation inflation qui persiste bien
sûr mais qui sera on l'espère enfin on
le le on l'anticipe à un niveau bien
moindre l'an prochain et mon objectif
pour le dire pour faire le lien entre le
techno et le politique c'est que le
l'ONDAM redevienne un objectif de
dépenses
que
les le ministère est chargé de tenir
puisque c'est la seule autorisation
parlementaire qui a et que on soit
beaucoup moins ce que ce que nous allons
encore être la situation dans laquelle
nous allons enêtre cette année
c'est-à-dire à demander au Parlement de
constater dans la
partie parti 1 et 2 du PLF SS des
dépassements majeurs de de objectif de
dépense qui a été voté précédemment vous
aurez à vous prononcer sur une
rectification de longame de 28 milliards
euh là en fin d'exercice ce n'est et je
je on ne pouvait entre guillemets pas
faire autrement puisqu'on constate plus
la dépense mais ce n'est si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi pas démocratiquement
satisfaisant d'engager au-delà donc moi
je je souhaite aussi et y compris en
assumant la contra que cela pose qu'on
revienne dans une dynamique dans
laquelle l'ONDAM est un objectif
national de dépenses et notre
responsabilité c'est d'essayer de le
tenir par ailleurs certains
beaucoup et je ne parle pas ici mais en
général ont oublié l'existence du comité
d'alerte qui de toute façon si nous
dérivons de la
trajectoire autant pendant le covid et
pendant l'inflation le comité d'alerte a
accepté d'être bienveillant sur sur sur
les dérives autant là il sera beaucoup
plus exigeant et donc ce contexte global
c'est quand même celui de la dégradation
de de du déficit de la branche
maladie même si on est passé de 21
milliards d'euros de déficit en 22 à 9
milliards en 23 euh nous mesurons que
que le chemin reste long enfin ou
difficile pour une situation soutenable
alors cette situation soutenable pour
moi elle doit elle doit rester notre cap
non pas uniquement évidemment pour des
raisons budgétaires mais parce que c'est
un point auquel je tiens beaucoup euh ce
que nous examinons quand nous examinons
et débattons du PLFSS c'est un système
d'assurance sociale euh qui appartient
aux assurés sociaux et dont au fond nous
ne sommes d'une certaine manière que les
régulateurs ou les garants mais moi je
je tiens à à valoriser
la performance de ce système d'assurance
sociale qui est capable d'encaisser des
coûts comme comme ça a été le cas
pendant le covid et qui au final sans
s'ans faire mais vous pourrez quand même
le dire à vos collègues de la commission
des finances 9 milliards d'euros de
déficit sur 255 milliards le jour où
l'État sera à ce ratio sur ces sur son
déficit c'est que il aura lui-même
nettement
progresser et donc cette soutenabilité
pour moi elle est aussi le moyen pour
dire les choses de main tenir le niveau
de socialisation de la dépense
d'Assurance Maladie Obligatoire tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire à 82
% un des plus hauts enfin le plus haut
en additionnant avec les 14 % derrière
d'assurance maladie complémentaire ce
qui porte à 96 % la socialisation de la
dépense de santé c'est un cap donc ce
cap de la soutenabilité qui garantit qui
doit qui est soutenu par la maîtrise des
dépens
euh voilà je crois qu'on le doit aux
assurés à l'ensemble des Français et on
doit aussi la transparence du coup sur
ce qui fait sur ce qui fait bouger et ce
qui fait ce qui rend la dynamique des
dépenses d'assurance maladie et suivre
ce cap et c'est là que notre équation
enfin celle du gouvernement et et celle
dont nous aurons à discuter ce matin
elle est elle est politiquement complexe
c'est que nous ne devons pas amoindrer
en notre soutien au plus fragile ni
repousser les investissements
indispensables à la à la à la
consolidation
ou à la resolidification de notre
système de santé que quand je dis
investissement je parle aussi bien
d'investissement dans des dans des
bâtiments hospitaliers avec notamment
les 19 milliards d'euros du Ségure que
investissement dans l'attractivité et
les fidélisations des personnels donc
l'esprit de de ce PLFSS c'est donc à la
fois de continuer à donner avoir la
priorité de l'accès au soins aux
produits de santé à la valorisation de
l'engagement des soignants et au virage
de la prévention et d'autres phar je le
dis et sans noute aons-nous l'occasion
d'en discuter de renforcer la pertinence
des dépenses et la responsabilité de
tous les acteurs face à la croissance
des dépenses de santé responsabilité de
tous les acteurs sans doute chaque mot
compte-t-il et nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir pour concrétiser ce double
engagement dans le PLFSS on trouve je
l'ai dit une rectification de LAM 23 à
hauteur de 2,8 milliards d'euros qui
intègre à la fois les les
revalorisations salariales euh des euh
du du de accordé au personnel de santé
mais aussi qui constate la dynamique des
des des soins de ville et qui qui
constate aussi l'impact de l'inflation
que nous avions sous-estimé puisqu'on
avait il y avait dans le PLFSS initial
750 millions d'euros pour l'inflation
mais c'est beaucoup plus et la deuxième
chose que l'on retrouve c'est une
progression de l'ONDAM de 3,2 % hors
dépenses liées à la crise sanitaire soit
une augmentation supérieure à la dépense
prévisionnelle enfin à l'inflation
prévisionnelle pardon qui est de de de
prévu à 25 hors tabac euh ce qui fait
une progression de moyen de l'ordre de 8
milliards d'euros ce qui me permet de
dire quand même juste en mot qu'on est
loin d'une trajectoire austéritaire 8
milliards d'euros c'était un effet
encore il y a 2 ans le budget total du
ministère de la Justice bien sûr pour
2000 24 cela représente un effort par
rapport au tendantiel de la dynamique de
dépense il y a aucun doute là-dessus et
le montant des économies à réalisé par
rapport à ce tendanciel est de 3
milliards et demi d'euros donc c'est
vrai qu'on rentre dans une on revient à
pour pour dire les choses je crois que
ça a été d'ailleurs évoqué un peu un peu
dans la dans la discussion sur le sur la
loi Valtou on revient dans une dans
une dans un texte financier qui va
essayer de modérer
la progression et la dynamique de
certaines dépenses des efforts de
modération des volumes et de baisse des
prix pour freiner la hausse des produits
de santé des produits de santé c'est
plus 7 % l'an dernier c'est le plus gros
bloc de dyamisme mais évidemment et
certains ici ou certaines en particulier
sont particulièrement pointus sur ça on
doit derrière les produits de santé il y
a beaucoup de choses il y a les matures
les produits innovant et cetera donc
voilà et des efforts d'efficience et de
pertinence tant pour les soins de ville
c'est ce que j'ai écrit dans la lettre
de cadrage de la négociation
conventionnelle que pour l'hôpital et je
je je j'assume ici de dire que oui on a
un sujet de pertinence aussi par exemple
dans la délivrance des médicaments à
l'osto ça ne ça ne fait pas de doute et
enfin des efforts de responsabilisation
des assurés on aura sans doute
l'occasion de parler de toutes les
pistes ouvertes et notamment des
franchises médicales comme ça il ça fait
10 minutes et j'ai prononcé le mot
euh voilà donc je je je finis le plus
rapidement possible en disant que ce
texte a deux grands objectifs le premier
et je ne dis pas que nous avons sold le
sujet au contraire mais c'était moi mon
but c'est de rendre irréversible ce
virage de la
prévention pas simplement en
l'illustrant par les éléments qui sont
dans le texte la vaccination contre les
infections liées au papillom virirus
pris en charge à 100 % ou la gratuité
des préservatifs pour les moins de de 26
ans ou encore la prise en charge des
protections menstruelles réutilisable
pour les moins de 26 ans et les plus
précaires euh ou des dispositifs sur
l'activité physique adapté je pense
qu'il y a des éléments sur la prévention
qui sont encore plus structurants et
notamment que de plus en plus prévention
et innovation ça va vouloir dire la même
chose en matière mais il y a des des
médecins qui sont beaucoup plus sachants
que moi autour de la table de médecinees
prédictives de personnalisation de la
médecine il y a qu'à voir aujourd'hui
sur le repérage et le traitement
anticipé du cancer des choses absolument
euh exceptionnelles qui sont qui sont en
train de se passer sous nos yeux et qui
vont être et qui vont changer la donne
le deuxième grand objectif de ce texte
c'est évidemment de de de moderniser le
fonctionnement du système de santé pourè
améliorer l'accès aux soins on continue
sur le meilleur partage des compétences
euh entre les différents professionnels
de santé euh Stéphanie Rist la
rapporteur général du pnfss à
l'Assemblée euh à a été très très engagé
sur ce texte aussi et et je sais que
c'est un sujet que vous suivez aussi
beaucoup ici euh pour élargir les
compétences des pharmaciens par exemple
en matière de prescription
d'antibiotiques avec la réalisation de
trod pour les angines et les cistit je
redis juste ce ce ces deux chiffres
parce que enine c'est 6 millions de
consultations par an chez le médecin
sistit c'est 3 millions euh je ne dis
pas que c'est l'alpha et l'oméga mais
tout ça dans le cadre évidemment de
protocole validé par la par la HAS et
dans l'idéal dans une vraie coopération
c'est-à-dire que si le pharmacien a un
doute sur la nature de la sistite et
qu'il soupçonne une piéoné frite il est
capable de de dans le cadre de sa CPTs
ou de voilà de de trouver le rendez-vous
chez le médecin qui va bien pour que la
personne puisse aller le voir le plus
vite possible euh élargissement aussi
des compétences vaccinales autour des
professionnels de proximité et euh et
puis on a dans ce PLF LSS la création
d'un forfait pluriactuel pluriacteur
pardon permettant de financant des
financer des équipes de soins dans une
logique de généralisation de certaines
expérimentations de l'article 51
derrière ce ce ce ce vocabulaire on a
quand même des expériences dans dans pas
mal d'endroits et c'est vrai à Paris
mais c'est vrai j'étais l'autre jour
dans le Tarne où on a des maisons de
santé pluripro avec des acteurs très
différents qui en fait seraiit mû pour
un financement plutôt à la capitation
plutôt que pour un financement à l'acte
voilà je ne dis pas que c'est vrai
partout mais ça peut l'être à certains
endroits euh donc on a des des
dispositifs qui vont rentrer dans le
droit commun qui permettent des parcours
de coopération un financement adaptable
au d'abord au besoins des patients enfin
le le PLFSS organise la réforme du
financement des des établissements de
santé avec une mesure dont on pour pour
à discuter qui est euh qui met fin au
caractère central de la T2A mais qui ne
met pas fin avec un objectif chiffré par
établissement mais plutôt par typologie
d'activité ce qui est moi le changement
que j'ai porté pour ne pas rester à
quelque chose d'un peu comptable il y a
des établissements qui qui font que de
la chirurgie très cadré très processé
ils resteront essentiellement financés à
la T2A tandis que un CHU ou de l'autre
côté un hôpital de proximité ont
d'autres responsabilités qui font qu'il
ne peuvent pas être financés pour
l'essentiel à la T2A le texte prévoit
aussi une meilleure articulation parce
que c'est un progrès auquel moi je
j'étais très je tenais beaucoup entre la
C2S et certains minimas sociaux dont la
location adulte handicapé pour toujours
l'accès plus facile à une
complémentaire des mesures que sur
lesquelles on pourra évidemment revenir
sur l'accès au médicaments et peut-être
me poserez-vous des questions aussi sur
l'actualité en la matière parce que nous
devons compléter les outils de gestion
des tensions d'approvisionnement et des
situations de pénurie que nous
connaissons périodiquement et il y
aurait rien de pire que d'avoir une
approche macro qui dit si si il y a
assez de stock sur le territoire
national alors que nos citoyens
concitoyens au niveau micro ils
vivent dans certains territoires ou même
au sein de certains territoires des
situations de pénurie euh voilà et donc
c'est là que je je je pense que
effectivement il faut rentrer plus
précisément dans la différence
entre médicaments et actes de diagnostic
innovant et accès aux produits plus
matures essentiels pour soigner les
Français euh voilà je je pardon d'avoir
été trop long parce qu'on m'avait
vraiment expliqué qu'il fallait être
beaucoup plus court au Sénat et je n'y
suis pas
parvenu totalement et je suis à votre
disposition mesdames et messieurs merci
monsieur le ministre et donc je vais
donner tout de suite la parole à
ellisabeth douanau rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces propos
liminires chers collègues je je vous
remercie d'avoir commencé par rappeler
les conclusions de la vie du comité
d'alerte c'est important et pour l'État
et c'est important pour nous tous parce
que c'est là que sont déterminé en
quelque sorte les limites à l'exercice
donc je je je renvoie mes collègues à la
lecture de de ce dernier avis mais mes
questions porteront sur trois aspects
mais surtout sur finalement
le regard budgétaire que je dois avoir
sur
cette sur ce projet de loi donc ma
première série de question ce sera sur
les revues de dépenses euh le deuxième
point sera sur la clause de sauvegarde
vous venez d' d'en parler un tout petit
peu et sur la fiscalité nutritionnelle
qui euh ici au
Sénat comment engendre des débats qui
sont tout à fait intéressants mais qui
prennent aussi beaucoup de temps et je
pense qu'on pourrait y travailler tous
ensemble alors alors sur les revues de
dépenses monsieur le ministre l'article
17 du projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques prévoit que des
économie issu du dispositif de revue de
dépenses instauré par l'article 167 de
la loi de finances pour 2023 et par
l'article 21 de la LPFP représente 6
milliards d'euros par an pour les années
2025 à 2027 et sont répartis entre les
dépenses des administrations de sécurité
sociale la rédaction de de du rapport
annexé au projet de la loi de
programmation suggère qu'il ne s'agira
pas de réaliser 6 milliards d'économies
supplémentaire chaque année mais
seulement de réaliser 6 milliards
d'euros d'économie en
2025 maintenu les années suivantes
confirmez-vous sur ce point parce que là
on a besoin d'une précision comment le
ministère de la Santé a-t-il été associé
aux revues de dépenses un objectif
global d'économie lui a-t-il été fixé
dans le cadre des revues de de dépenses
et la Cour des comptes a établi en
juillet 2023 dans le cadre des revues de
dépenses une note thématique relative à
la médecine de ville dans laquelle elle
préconise notamment pour maîtriser les
dépenses une réforme des modalités de
négociation de l'assurance maladie avec
les professionnels de santé et on le
voit d'ailleurs dans la note du comité
d'alerte il s'agirait notamment de
donner aux ministres le pouvoir de
prendre les mesures nécessaires en cas
d'échec des négociations dans tous les
champs conventionnels et d'inscrire les
dépense de soins de ville dans une
stratégie et des trajectoires
pluri-annuelles quelle est votre
appréciation sur la clause de sauvegarde
nous savons les uns et les autres que la
première ministre a récemment préconisé
de ramener à moyen terme le produit de
la taxe à un niveau proche de 0,5
milliards d'euros dans le cadre d'un
comité d'experts qu'elle a initié nous
en sommes loin puisque je le rappelle la
clause a explosé et devrait s'établir à
1,6 milliards en 2023 nous avions évoqué
ce sujet en fin de mandature la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur les
pénuries de médicaments avait souligné
que ce dispositif conçu comme une corde
de rappel budgétaire n'était pas taillé
pour devenir un outil fin de régulation
des dépenses il frappe notamment c'était
notre conclusion tous les médicaments
indépendamment de leur intérêt
thérapeutique ou de leur criticité
industrielle en tant que ministre de la
Santé seriez-vous favorable à ce que la
régulation des dépenses de médicaments
intègre mieux les enjeux
d'approvisionnement qui deviennent
majeur dans notre pays faut-il mieux
protéger dans l'application de la clause
de sauvegarde les médicaments essentiels
à la prise en charge des patients ou
ceux dont la chaîne de production et le
niveau de rentabilité apparaissent
particulièrement
fragile sur le dernier point la
fiscalité nutritionnelle pourrait
constituer une source de recette
intéressante comme globalement la
réduction des risques et je pense qu'on
on n parle pas assez on pourrait
poursuivre un objectif de santé publique
prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires et du diabète de type
2 sur le surpoids et l'obésité également
en France seul les boissons sucrées et
édulcoré font l'objet d'une taxation
spécifique à viser comportemental à à
l'exclusion des autres aliments cette
taxation a rapporté 600 millions d'euros
en 2022 ayant été réformé en 2018 elle
devait faire l'objet d'une évaluation
pour l'automne 2023 sous la coordination
de la Direction générale de la santé
pour apprécier ses impacts sur le choix
des consommateurs en juillet 2023 le
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires a
diffusé une note qui encourage à la mise
en œuvre d'une telle fiscalité avec deux
recommandation à court terme réformer la
fiscalité actuelle sur les boissons
sucrées etdulcoré en augmentant les
barêmes des contributions sur ces
produits et en élargissant l'assiette
aux boissons à base de soja voire au
sirop le CPO préconise aussi qu'une
évaluation de cette fiscalité dont les
conditions ont été modifiées en 2018 est
en cours et devait être et communiqué à
l'automne 2023 ce qui pourra servir de
base à une nouvelle réforme et puis à
moyen terme c'est aussi étudier
l'extension de cette fiscalité au
produits sucrés ou contenant des
addictifs nocifs pour la santé
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre si une telle mesure fait
l'objet de travaux du gouvernement et
pouvez-vous nous faire part des
hypothèses qui ont été étudiées et
chiffrées en terme de recette je vous
remercie peut-être c'est déjà de
répondre à ces premières questions et
ensuite je la parole à
cor d'accord euh merci merci Madame la
rapporteur générale peut-être
euh sur les revues des dépenses d'abord
effectivement on a un un cadre
euh qui est la loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui fixe un objectif
et un niveau d'ond d'ame pour les années
les années à venir et à partir de là
évidemment on peut en déduire le le
montant de de maîtrise de la de la
dépense qui va qui va ten qui va ten qui
va pardon en découler donc euh il y a
euh aujourd'hui euh un chiffre qui est
entre entre 5 et 6 milliards
effectivement euh d'ici
2025 à documenter encore une fois 5 à 6
milliards euh d'économie sur euh sur une
progression mais parce que la la
situation de la de la population
enfin comment dirais-je les maladies
chroniques et le vieillissement de la
population la l'intégration des impacts
et des déterminants environnementaux sur
la santé rien ne laisse présager une
baisse de la dépense de santé donc c'est
toujours par rapport à un tendantiel
H il y a donc une partie qui va être
accompagné par
euh effectivement des travaux
strictosensu de revue des dépenses quand
je dis strictosensus c'est-à-dire une
lettre de mission adressé par la
première ministre à des inspections pour
accompagner pour creuser des pistes je
pense notamment au travaux que que que
l'on va engager sur un sujet qui est qui
est compliqué je trouve et sur lequel
certains par ailleurs ont des avis très
arrêté qui est celui des dispositifs
médicaux que ce soit en en ville ou à
l'hôpital et sur
l'évaluation en continu je veux dire
durable de leur efficience et de leur et
de leur et de leur pertinence ce qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui on n' pas un
dispositif aussi sophistiqué sur les
dispositifs médicaux donc là il y a
besoin d'un travail extrêmement
extrêmement nourri et puis euh moi je le
je le je le formule ici je
formule C éléments qui pour moi
sont les axes et dont une partie je
souhaiterais pouvoir au-delà des
discussions qu'on peut avoir quelques
semaines avant le
PLFSS que nous puissions y travailler
avec les parlementaires le plus en amont
possible je les cite l'un que vous avez
indirectement cité madame douanau qui
est je pense qu'on est sans aucun doute
au stade où la question du remboursement
pour le dire plus plus cche des
médicaments à faible intérêt
euh médical les remboursements à 15 %
euh doit être ouverte
elle rétroagit évidemment sur la
question on y reviendra du rapport avec
les laboratoires puisque on va retrouver
voilà mais
euh si je dis les choses trivialement
euh on a aimé l'homéopathie on peut bon
c'est un sujet où on va se se se on va
avoir du travail mais je pense que dans
la situation où on est quand les
dépenses de santé de médicaments
progressent de 7 % par an on est obligé
de se poser cette question là et je
pense que ça ça ça mérite qu'on en
discute bien
avant juste le PLFSS pour dire les
choses simplement le deuxième élément
pour moi c'est euh le sujet euh de la
pertinence dans euh euh dans
euh flute le mot à l'instant
euh les médecins dans les dans les ben
ça est si si même ce mot m'échappe je
pense que je devais devoir aller me me
me me cacher donc c'est de la pertience
dans les prescriptions pardon
euh et j'ai mis cet élément dans la
lettre de cadrage au directeur général
de l'assurance maladie je l'ai explicit
itement formulé parce que je pense
aujourd'hui qu'on est encore on a encore
des progrès à faire et qu'on a des
outils qui permettent d'accompagner les
médecins là là-dedans donc c'est tout le
travail qui va être celui de la
négociation conventionnelle très
clairement la négociation
conventionnelle on retient l'objectif de
on retient l'objectif
des de de de la revendication sur le C à
30 € euh du côté du gouvernement moi je
souhaite pousser à la responsabilisation
dans la prescription et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'on a encore une fois des
des outils qui permettent de de d'aller
plus loin et je pense même que une
partie des professionnels de santé ou
des des pharmaciens quelquefois constate
le le le le le fait que que que on y va
fort sur certains sur certaines
prescriptions et je quand je dis
responsabilisation je le le dit aussi
pardon on va prendre cet exemple trivial
mais
oui ce message il passe aussi par le
fait de se dire je vais chez le médecin
euh je vais si je prends mon exemple je
vais direct à la pharmacie avant de
rentrer chez moi et quand j'arrive avec
mes trois enfants il est très rare que
j'ai pas déjà l'intégralité des produits
dans ma dans ma pharmacie mais comme
chaque Français rêverait d'être
pharmacien c'est vrai que du coup ça
fait ça fait voilà donc donc je je
pousse la caricature un peu loin mais
vous avez tous en tête le moment où vous
avez votre 4e truc de pivalon qui se qui
qui du coup comme ça a trois frères et
sœurs mais je je pense que là-dessus le
point suivant c'est que je pense que on
a un sujet sur la fraude sur les fraudes
devrais-je dire
les fraudes euh encore une fois enfin
encore une fois je ne l'ai pas dit pour
l'instant mais je le dis ici les fraudes
les plus
massives suivent totalement la courbe
des revenus hein elles sont pas elles
sont pas elles ont pas une un sens
inverse les les plus gros fraudeurs sont
les les les plus gros bénéficiaires
c'est voilà et donc et aujourd'hui donc
on a un sujet notamment sur le sujet des
professionnels de santé aussi mais je je
ne souhaite pas pour dire pour répondre
à Mame doano précisément l'ouvrir par le
biais d'une revue des dépenses moi je
pense que ça ça se discute ça se travail
dans le cadre conventionnel
essentiellement et oui aujourd'hui
l'assurance maladie a des outils pour
repérer des parcours de
soins quand vous avez 1000 patients qui
font exactement le même parcours de
soins dans tel département on peut se
dire qu'il y a quelque chose autour de
ça qui voilà il passe du même
généraliste au même spécialiste du même
spécialiste à l'autre même spécialiste
et il est traité par le même pharmacien
il y a quelque chose qui doit se repérer
pour aller voir ce qui se passe donc ça
c'est la la je pense que la fraude est
un élément important et par ailleurs je
le crois profondément la fraude est est
quelque chose et un un poison pour notre
contrat social donc il faut y aller le
et puis il y a deux éléments qui jouent
aussi indirectement euh c'est enfin
c'est que je crois et ce travail mais je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on parvienne à le
conduire en un an mais je le dis je
pense
qu'aujourd'hui notre outil de
financement et de pilotage de la dépense
qui est
l'AM si nous arrivons à engager
structurellement ce virage de la
prévention l'ONDAM euh mais je crois que
vous l'avez même dit hier en séance
l'ONDAM
but sur cette réalité làà
puisque un bénéfice à à moyen terme la
dépense à court terme donc voilà donc je
pense qu'on a inventer un dispositif de
de de pilotage de la dépense de
prévention autant c'est simple sur
bfortus on verra combien ça nous a coûté
on verra si ça a fait significativement
éviter des hospitalisations et cetera
autant sur d'autres dispositifs on
finance avec
longam 23 la vaccination
HPV qui produira les résultats dans
longtme 2050 donc du coup c'est sûr
qu'on a un sujet autour de ça il est
très compliqué à à traiter mais je pense
qu'il est devant nous et puis il y a le
sujet du rôle des complémentaires où on
doit des organismes complémentaires au
sens large et c'est complémentairire
c'est un monde évidemment très très
hétérogène entre les mutuels au sein
même des mutuels ou avec ou avec les
banques les banques assureurs et cetera
ou c'est quelle est leur contribution
euh à ce à ce à ces sujet euh il y a des
moments où on arrive à avoir des
dispositifs vertueux les la l'assurance
maladie assiné notamment avec les avec
les complémentaires et les
dentistes quelque chose qui valorise la
prévention voilà et mais moi je voudrais
qu'on sorte du simple de la de la
facilité entre guillemets mais qui est
qui est souvent nécessaire où on où le
gouvernement
récupère du du du de l'argent des
complémentaires pour plutôt les
embarquer sur des projets type par
exemple la prévention est-ce que on
arriverait là-dessus à être plus plus fa
ça fait le lien avec la clause avec ce
que vous évoquez sur le le
médicament la clause de sauvegarde euh
comment diraisje mais mais mais d'une
certaine
manière on a on a deux deux levier
généralement pour maîtriser la dépense
de de MOC par rapport au
labo le niveau de de de négociation sur
les prix c'est 1 milliard dans le PLFSS
24 et le dispositif de clause de
sauvegarde ce dispositif de clause de
sauvegarde si cette année si on le
laissait jouer à plein il rapporterait à
l'état entre enfin exactement il y
aurait un retour entre 1 milliard 6 1
milliard 7 1 milliard 8 et l'an prochain
on serait beaucoup plus haut plutôt
autour de 200 milliards 4 il est clair
pour moi qu'un dispositif qui est soit
qui théoriquement de sauvegarde à partir
du moment où il se met à avoir un
rendement de ce niveau-là c'est qu'on a
un problème sur la conception même de
notre de notre de notre de notre
dispositif et par ailleurs avec des
laboratoires qui sont dans des
situations extrêmement diff différent
entre les génériqueur d'un côté les
produits innovants de l'autre et cetera
donc je pense qu'on a
refondé pour ma part ce ce schéma et
c'est vrai que le PLF ss24 comporte un
capage de la clause de sauvegarde à 100
Millard 6 mais qui parallèlement nous
nous nous nous nous amène à être plus
exigeant notamment vous avez évoqué ou
on l'a évoqué
sur l'accès aux médicaments Essen sur
les pénuries et cetera mais je voudrais
dire peut-être deux choses sur ce
point-là le premier c'est que les
pénuries on a mis en place un fond de
souveraineté entre guillemets qui est
pas identifié comme tel mais qui permet
sur certains médicamament de proposer
ponctuellement à des laboratoires une
augmentation du prix en échange d'une de
de du fait qu'ils assurent des livraison
à la France on l' on l'a activé dès
cette année par le biais du du CEP s du
Conseil économique des produits de
santé une bonne partie des laboratoires
ont répondu présent mais certains non
n'ont pas
souhaité et c'est un sujet qu'on croise
que tous les pays
d'Europe rencontrent voilà ça ne veut
pas dire que ça nous ça nous dispense
d'essayer de de trouver des des sujets
mais on a premièrement ce sujet clause
de sauvegarde pour pour activer euh et
puis on a évidemment aussi euh le sujet
ù moi je je veux le redire ici devant
cette commission nous ne sommes pas en
retard sur l'accès aux médicaments
innovant parce que il y a un il y a un
lobbying qui est fait notamment par les
laboratoires pour expliquer qu'on serait
en retard que c'est catastrophique que
c'est tout ça en fait je je je je je
quand on progresse de 7,7 % dans la
dépense de mdoc c'est c'est tiré par les
médicaments innovants et et les
comparaisons notamment qui ont été
faites elles pent notamment avec
d'autres pays sur des
médicaments il n'y a même même pas eu de
demande d'AMM en France donc du coup
c'est c'est un peu c'est un peu
croquignolé donc nous ne sommes pas en
retard ça tire et donc évidemment il y a
derrière aussi la question du du bon
usage qu'on va retrouver dans la
négociation conventionnelle mais pour
répondre à votre
question on a ce dispositif
il n'est pas entièrement satisfaisant à
ce stade on voit bien qu'on doit
restructurer notre négociation et
parallèlement parce que nous sommes un
pays dans lequel l'industrie
pharmaceutique est forte j'allais dire y
compris dans les territoires c'est une
des seules industrie qui est très
disséminée et l'industrie des
l'industrie également des dispositifs
médicaux on a aussi à faire revenir en
terme de réindustrialisation sur le
territoire donc c'est vrai qu'on gère
des contraintes qui sont qui sont
difficiles est contradictoire mais si
demain Pierre Fabre partait euh du Tarne
je crois ça serait un petit sujet euh VO
c'était pour vous pour la
S donc ça serait un petit sujet donc
voilà donc on est on est sur ce sur ce
ce point là dernier point fiscalité
nutritionnelle euh pour être très
direct moi je suis très preneur des
propositions qui seront faites si euh on
a cet éternel
sujet de la de la du fait de trouver
l'équilibre entre ne pas dire aux
Français comment ils doivent vivre et
s'ils veulent manger des trucs voilà
voilà parce que parce que voilà mais en
même temps d'être de leur donner les
éléments parce que c'est à terme un
impact de santé publique et donc ben il
y a eu c'est là que je regrette il y
avait eu des propositions dans la dans
la commission d'affaires sociales
assemblée on n' pas forcément pu en
discuter je je le dis ici moi je suis
ouvert à ce sujet même si vous savez
tous que il y a sur la fiscalité
comportementale enfin ou sur ou sur la
version de ne serait-ce que
l'information systématique voilà moi je
je reste convaincu que le nutriscore par
exemple qui progresse il faut maintenir
ce ce caractère volontaire parce que les
les les les les flutes les industrielles
euh le le le porte et sont engagés
dedans mais le débat doit et peut avoir
lieu ici moi je j'y suis évidemment tout
à fait prês pardon monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup non non c'est parfait je
donne la parole maintenant à
corinebert merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre
euh sans surprise je vais je vais
commencer mon propos par londame un
longame qui atteint un montant assez
vertigineux puisque pour la première
fois il va dépasser 250 milliards
d'euros alors je partage avec vous
l'idée que l'ondame doit revenir à ce
qu'il doit être c'est-à-dire une
autorisation parlementaire de dépenses
nous avions euh et et le Sénat n'oublie
pas le comité d'alerte parce que nous
avions souhaité en lofs une clause de
retour devant le Parlement avec un une
borne à 1 % 1 % c'est 2,5 milliards
d'euros voilà alors vous allez nous
présenter une une correction de l'AM
2023 2 milliard 8 si j'ai bien compris
euh des sous-objectifs importants
montant euh puisque les dépenses de soin
de ville vont approcher 110 milliards
d'euros le financement donc le le
deuxème objectif pour le financement des
établissements de santé publique et
privée dépasse les 105 millions d'euros
euh vous pourriez peut-être monsieur le
ministre euh j'allais dire découper ces
objectifs pour affiner qu'on ait euh
peut-être un regard plus plus oui plus
affiné sur ce que représente pour rien
que pour ces deux enveloppes les 200
milliards d'euros cumulés
alors deux questions sur sur ce point
financier comment expliquez-vous l'état
notre système de santé la crise dans
laquelle celui-ci
s'enfonce vous n'avez pas vous n'avez
pas 4 He mais vous vous rendez compte
j'en suis sûr pour la première fois ça
va dépasser 250 milliards d'euros et si
on faisait un petit sondage qui est
content qui a le sentiment qu'on a
beaucoup de chance d'avoir une sécurité
sociale qui dépense autant
pour la santé quand même un petit sujet
me
semble-t-il la seconde tout aussi simple
mais vous n'aurez pas 4 He non plus sur
la soutenabilité financière de
l'assurance maladie j'ai j'ai j'ai posé
la question au directeur de l'acnam
comment allons-nous éviter la banque
route vous voyez que les questions sont
courtes deè sujet l'hôpital un sujet que
nous connaissions bien ancienne
présidente de cette commission Catherine
deoche avait l'an passé apporter une
commission d'enquête le gouvernement
prévoit une réforme des modalités de
financement du champ médecine chirurgie
obstétrique si j'ai bien compris vous
prévoyez une réforme à budget
constant donc soit il s'agit d'une
réforme qu'on pourrait qualifier de
cosmétique qui se borne à modifier le
nom de compartiment de financement à
créer une usine à gaz qui
fera des mécontents forcément et puis à
ce moment-là bon on pourrait peut-être
s'en passer soit agit d'une réforme qui
aura des effets redistributifs et donc
qui fera des mécontents et alors qui
seront les gagnants et les
perdants plusieurs mesures concernent
les produits de santé dans ce PLFSS
alors comme le temps passe je vais
parevenir sur le contenu de ces articles
mais évidemment plusieurs de ces mesures
étaient préconisé par la commission
d'enquête du Sénat qui a rendu son
rapport l'été dernier j'évoque les
pénuries de médicaments les effets
rupture et et tension
j'ai rien vu dans le PLFSS concernant la
liste de près de 400 médicaments
essentiels publiés par le ministère
l'été dernier rien non plus qui permett
d'améliorer vraiment l'anticipation des
ruptures même si les laboratoires ont un
devoir de prévenir les risque de rupture
les risques de
tension où en est la la la feuille de
route du du gouvernement sur les
pénuries qui était attendu et comment
entendez-vous lutter efficacement contre
les phénomènes de pénurie donc et
empêcher toute rupture sur ces 450
médicaments essentiels identifiés l'été
dernier par les sociétés savantes euh
ensuite une question sur l'article 27
qui vise à réguler les dépenses
d'indébnité journalière maladie
pensez-vous qu'il soit réaliste de
réduire ses dépenses par un contrôle
accru des prescriptions dès lors que la
hausse des dernières années hein puisque
nous avons plus 3,8 % moyenne annuelle
depuis 2010 est en partie je dis bien en
partie porté par des déterminants
exogènes sans lien avec des arrêts non
justifiés je pense au vieillissement de
la population active à l'ouverture des
indemnités journalières aux professions
libérales en 2021 à la double grippe
saisonnière en 2022 et bien sûr à la
progression des des pathologies liées à
la santé mentale les syndicats de
médecins libéraux voi dans la suspension
automatique des indemnités journalières
après contevisite médicale des médecins
contrôleurs une remise en cause de leurs
compétences de prescription n'avez-vous
pas peur que cette mesure ne détériore
davantage le climat des relations
conventionnelles
enfin de de
points vous avez à plusieurs reprises
évoqué monsieur le ministre le
doublement de la franchise médicale et
la participation forfaitaire qui je vous
cite était sur la table et qui était une
une option qui serait sans doute retenue
dans le cadre du budget de la Sécurité
sociale la mesure n'est pas du tout
inscrite dans le projet de loi ce qui
est logique parce qu'elle semble être
davantage d'ordre réglementaire donc ma
question est simple avez-vous pris votre
décision monsieur le ministre
au sujet du doublement de la franchise
médicale et de la participation
financière et comptevous oui ou non
mettre en œuvre cette mesure et enfin
vous
avez évoqué le médicament des des
peut-être des déremboursements de
médicaments qui aujourd'hui sont
remboursés à à 15 % par l'assurance
maladie euh attention aux effets de bord
il faudrait pas qu'il a des report de
prescription sur des médicaments qui
seraient remboursés à 30 % par
l'assurance maladie parce que là benah
écoute ça coûterait plus cher et puis ça
encourage là encore euh les euh les
complémentaires à à proposer des paniers
de soins à leurs assurés avec des
forfaits annuels pour rembourser des
médicaments non remboursés voilà et donc
on accentue encore ces c'est ces une
dégradation de notre système très
solidaire qui est la sécurité sociale je
vous remercie par avance de vos réponses
monsieur le ministre n attendons vos
réponses oui je je je elles sont elles
sont simples du coup je vais le faire en
sens inverse pour euh non mais je je
pardon je je n'ai pas annoncer ici le
déremboursement des médicaments à 15 %
je dis je pense que
euh le travail sur ce sujet mérite
d'être lancé euh ça a été dit du reste
dans les entretiens Mo que j'ai eu avec
des des des député avant le PLFSS euh je
pense qu'il mérite d'être lancé mais que
vous avez cité une partie des effets de
bord que je pense tout à fait
réel mais simplement
euh dans ça renverra la question par
laquelle je finirai dans le le la
perspective de la soutenabilité le fait
de revenir à l'intérêt médical d'un
médicament pour justifier de la
socialisation de son coup me semble être
plutôt plutôt sain mais mais évidemment
euh vous avez évoqué les reports les
effets de bord je rajoute je le disais
tout à l'heure des
médicaments très prescrit dans des labos
Français installés dans une seule usine
dans un département je vois enfin on
voit d'ici on voit d'ici le le le sujet
donc c'est c'est pour ça que pour ma
part je considérais que ça méritait euh
une forme de de de de travail entre le
le le gouvernement et le Parlement tout
au long de la euh pour pour documenter
pour savoir ce que ça veut dire je je
pense que c'est essentiel et je pense
que de toute façon au-delà de la
situation euh de la situation de à
l'Assemblée nationale
euh je veux dire on ne peut pas franchir
des réformes de cette ampleur qui ont un
tel impact sur nos
concitoyens si on n pas de la
transparence sur le débat démocratique
sur ces sujets et pas par ailleurs
accessoirement moi je n'ai pas la je ne
je ne je ne sais pas répondre exactement
ce je dis juste quand je vois le la
somme des contraintes dans laquelle on
est euh et ce que ça représente je pense
que ça vaut le coup d'ouvrir la le le le
sujet d'ouvrir le sujet je ne sais mais
je n je ne l'ai pas présenté comme une
solution
miracle deuxièmement sur les
vous avez raison Madame la rapporteur en
soulignant d'abord que
le dynamisme des igiS le dynamisme pour
dire l'augmentation extrêmement forte
des igiS est d'abord
tiré par l'augmentation de la population
active et que donc ça on peut dire aussi
que c'est d'abord une bonne nouvelle
puisque c'est le le le corollaire de la
de la baisse de la baisse du chômage
qu'on constatait jusqu'à présent
deuxè 2è élément pour être tout à fait
clair là aussi ce qui coûte de très loin
le plus cher dans les igiS ce sont les
igiS très longues pour les maladies très
longues donc en fait ça renvoie au sujet
de la qualité de vie au travail de la
prévention de la reconversion
professionnelle sujet qui était
d'ailleurs mentionné dans la conférence
sociale qui a eu lieu il y a quelques
jours mais je penseil faut pas se
tromper de de de cble c'est vrai enfin
que ce qui est frappant quand on regarde
le tableau il y a une explosion au sens
propre des igiS sur les plus jeunes de
de nos
concitoyens où les indemnités
journalières explosent ça elles
explosent en en volume en coup c'est
moins de 5 % des is c'est pour ça qu'il
faut le il faut le redire et ce que je
trouve au fond le plus important c'est
de comprendre ce que ça
signifie parce que c'est le signal de
quelque chose sur un rapport au travail
dont on parle tous sans savoir
exactement de quoi on parle sur tous ces
sujets mais moi ma préoccupation
principale c'est et ça fait le lien avec
une réforme qui a suscité un
enthousiasme
immodéré sur la réforme des retraites
c'est le ce qu'on fait
sur des personnes qui à 50 ans ont été
fracassé par leur travail ou par leur
vie en général qui doivent pouvoir se
reconvertir qui doivent pouvoir quand
elles ont été catégorie active ne pas se
dire qu'elles doivent aller jusqu'au
bout de leur vie en catégorie active et
qu'il a un portage de ce de ce sujet-l
et où il faut des mesures en matière de
prévention beaucoup plus fortes je pense
que ce sont des des des des axes qui
sont dans la réforme des retraite mais
qui concernent très directement derrière
aussi la santé publique donc moi je je
voilà ensuite le dernier point je le dis
quand même c'est que oui
euh mais je sais pas si c'est devant le
le scénna hier que je le disais parce
que à force je me je me je je je je je
pardon je mes idées sont moins claires
oui on a quand même des professionnels
de santé des médecins qui prescrivent
euh trois fois quatre fois plus digj
avec des redressements de patientelle
que fait la l'assurance maladie que leur
confrère moi à titre personnel ça ne me
choque pas que l'assurance maladie dans
un dialogue confraternel comme l'ont dit
aille voir avec eux quelle est la
réalité parce que dans l'autre sens dans
toutes les visites que je fais vous en
faites plus que moi vous avez tous
croisé le jeune médecin qui prescrit
parce que c'est une une douleur lombaire
ou parce que la personne est pas bien et
il prescrit et quand il reçoit la lettre
de l'assurance maladie qui lui dit vous
prescrivez trop c'est il se sent empêché
de soigner d'une certaine manière donc
c'est c'est très c'est très compliqué
c'est pas du tout simpliste comme comme
comme sujet donc je je mais mais je
pense qu'il faut pardon du terme
banaliser le fait que quand on a quand
on est vraiment très au-dessus encore
une fois en ayant redressé les éléments
de patientelle c'est pas la même chose
d'être dans dans des dans le 7e
arrondissement de Paris que d'être dans
le bassin minier dans le Nord on a des
des on doit pouvoir dialoguer avec
l'assurance maladie on a un travail avec
l'assurance a dit par ailleurs pour dire
les pour c'est une ça pour paraître
anecdotique mais pour qu'on retravaille
leur courriers euh qui sont quelquefois
euh des courriers euh
ou euh qui donneent envie de se de se de
voilà
cominatoire merci madame la sénatrice je
vous salue nous nous étions pas vu
depuis le griffon voilà donc donc on a
nos petites histoire donc voilà euh donc
je j'entends ce que vous dites sur la
suspension automatique
euh j'entends ce que vous dites sur
enfin donc il y a deux sujets il y a
l'article 7 sur la fraude et les
conséquences et l'article 27 donc sur la
suspension automatique sans repasser par
le
médecin de de l'assurance maladie je je
je pareil enfin je le dis très
simplement et très librement c'est un
sujet dont moi je je suis prêt à à
rediscuter il est un irritant ça ne fait
pas de doute dans les dans les
discussions voilà mais c'était aussi un
un symbole un peu fort de dire en fait
euh voilà on remet on remet cette cette
notion de de contrôle
euh sur les les médicaments alors je je
je devrais je devrais les
445 médicaments euh on les suit et
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament les suit j'étais euh et c'est
pour ça que j'étais en retard euh avec
votre concert la présidente de l'Ordre
des
pharmaciens ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a
un problème je le dis très simplement
entre des chiffres macros où euh on suit
les stocks nationaux
d'amooxyiline euh notamment de dolipran
et cetera qui sont plus élevés que l'an
dernier
euh où on a du stock pour X semaines et
des pharmacies qui vivent et la
pharmacie de ma de votre confrère et de
ma collègue ministre délégué étant mon
mon le thermomètre quotidien puisque
j'ai j'ai un texto tous les jours avec
le stock d'amoxyyine chez la pharmacie
Du du Havre en
question je je il y a quelques chose
entre les deux qui ne qui ne
fonctionnent pas donc c'est vrai et j'ai
eu des propos qui avait été qui ont été
donc maladroit puisqu'ils ont été mal
compris euh on a constaté moi j'ai
demandé à la NSM de regarder de plus
près ce qui se passait sur le circuit
voilà et on a constaté notamment que les
plus grosses pharmacies notamment les
groupes avaient tendance à passer
par-dessus les grossistes répartiteurs
et commander directement des industriels
pour stocker ce qui est un comportement
tout à fait rationnel quand on a connu
des pinuriies mais du coup les
industriels vont d'abord vers eux et
ensuite vers euh voilà donc des petites
pharmacies ou des moyennes n'arrivent
pas à délivrer donc ça moi je demandais
à la NSM de de de de de remettre un peu
d'ordre là-dedans mais on suit ces ces
médicaments on a je le disais le fond de
souveraineté et puis on a aussi je pense
vous le vous le vous le vivez sans doute
dans votre exercice le dispositif dont
j'ai oublié le nom là le votre votre
dispositif de si rupture qui a été mis
en place voilà d'p rupture où en fait en
temps réel les pharmaciens je crois que
c'est 98 % des pharmaciens qui sont
connectés au DP rupture font remonter
les ruptures et donc moi je souhaite et
s'il y a une proposition de loi en la
matière je la soutiendrai que ce dép
rupture devienne un outil de
gestion ça pour qu'on puisse en
permanence confronter ce que nous disent
les industriels voilà avec la situation
réelle on a besoin d'un bout de loi pour
pour le le
généraliser je je on aurait peut-être on
aurait peut-être pu l'anticiper mais le
ça nurait ça aurait été un cavalier en
LFSS de toute façon donc donc voilà mais
on est
mobilisé je veux pas pas surjouer mais
moi je me fais tous les
jours faire un point sur la
situation et à la fin ce qui se fera la
différence c'est le la violence des
épidémies hivernales tout de même
mais c'est vrai donc je me garde bien de
dire à nos concitoyens il y a pas de
problème puisqueen niveau macro on a 20
% de stock de plus que l'an dernier
parce qu'il y a rien de pire quand vous
avezit trois pharmacies et qu'il y a un
abruti de ministre qui vous dit qu'il y
a pas de pénuriie donc voilà donc c'est
c'est voilà vous avez alors maintenant
on entre dans les questions celles sur
lesquelles j'ai 4 heures et je m'en
réjouis euh
euh je ne je la réforme de la T2A enfin
plus exactement la réforme du
financement j'ai essayé d'en dire un mot
tout à l'heure il y avait le président
de la République et pas que lui depuis
des
années et beaucoup d'entre vous ont été
présidents du conseil de surveillance
d'ostau je vois Bernard jaumier ou ou
annis à la PHP on a ce sujet sur c'est
la T2A qui est en partie responsable de
la de la situation moi le ce que j'ai
essayé de faire enfin j'ai essayé pardon
les services les équipes avec avec les
professionnels c'est de sortir d'une
logique dans laquelle on dirait il faut
que plus de 50 % de la rémunération d'un
établissement soit fondé sur du H T2A
mais qu'on arrive à identifier des
compartiments et des typologies de soins
qui en fait pondre à la T2A et de je le
disais tout à l'heure normalement une de
de l'orthopédie ambulatoire c'est fait
partout pareil ça la la T2A ça doit bien
marcher pour ça il y a pas de sujet et
puis vous avez d'un côté les CHU où on a
toute une une série enfin où les de gros
hôpitaux généraux qui font du recours
qui ont les cas les plus lourds et
notamment dans le public il faut qu'ils
aient des dotations plutôt parce que que
la T2A ne ne permet pas de prendre en
compte toutes leurs spécificités et les
charges spécifiques liées à leur
situation donc à la fin on fait de la
bidouille en fin d'année pour essayer de
avec les les les les les les mairies les
voilà et cetera ça je je voilà et de
l'autre côté du spectre il y a les
sujets de santé publique dans laquelle
on veut que les hôpitaux s'engage euh et
qui sont aussi le fait d'avoir une
présence de maintenir des activités qui
sont pas forcément rentables au sens de
voilà donc on les finance pour maintenir
ce type d'activité dès lors qu'elles ont
les professionnel pour le faire et à la
fin moi ma mon objectif n'est pas de
dire tous les établissements seront
financés par une part minoritaire de T2A
mon objectif il est de dire les le un
établissement il sera financé par les
différentes dotation qui correspondent à
la diversité de son de son exercice
après vous avez poser une question qui
est évidemment essentielle et sur
laquelle je ne sais pas répondre euh
pour dire les choses clairement parce
que c'est pas pour le plaisir qu'on fait
une usine à gaz honnêtement les réformes
des tarifications pour ceux qui ont
suivi celle sur la SSR ou celle sur la
psychiatrie euh quand vous dites à la
dgo à la direction générale de l'offre
de soins on va faire une réforme de la
tarification euh c'est effrayant on le
fait parce qu'on pense que c'est une
bonne mesure à la à la fin
mais les effets de bord comme comme
enfin vous avvez peut-être pas employé
ce terme mais en fait les effets
redistributifs on a aujourd'hui du mal à
les à les évaluer donc on sait les
évaluer pour à peu près pour
200024 et après on verra et on va suivre
progressivement de toute façon tout ceci
se mettra en œuvre progressivement mais
je ne sais vous normalement j'allais
dire sur le papier et théoriquement
cette réforme doit mieux s'ajuster euh à
la situation des différents Ostau mais
je n'ai pas de doute sur le fait qu'il
va y avoir euh des perdant qu'on navait
pas identifié
euh comme sur des ré d'autres types de
réformes c'est un peu comme le sujet
classique pardon il y a pas de je sais
pas s'il y a des élus ultramarins ici du
coefficient géographique où tout le
monde nous réclame de le remettre à plat
et cetera mais aujourd'hui il y a des il
y aurait si on reprenait sur les
critères objectifs il y aurait des
perdants si on reprena le coefficient
géographique voilà donc je je je je je
le dis comme ça donc typiquement moi je
considère là aussi que la le suivi de la
mise en place de cette réforme de la
tarification c'est un sujet sur lequel
le ministre il doit pas être juste
auditionné la veille du PLFSS et que moi
je dois rendre des comptes au Parlement
sur ce qui se passe au cours de l'année
euh je j'envisageais enfin je je il y a
différentes modalités de de rend du
compte mais y compris sur le un rapport
au Parlement sur ces sujets je trouve
que ça serait tout à fait euh normal de
d'y pass d'y d'y passer euh Allis je
dire de façon triviale la dernière
question qui était donc la première euh
est évidemment euh est évidemment
redoutable
euh d'une part quand même
euh si nous étions dans une situation
totalement totalement euh unique dans le
monde Je je je je me dirais euh on a un
problème j'étais l'autre jour en
Allemagne avec mon collègue allemand
leur situation c'est toujours quand on
compare avec l'Allemagne et que c'est
pire que nous ça fait toujours euh ça
fait toujours de plaisir mais mais euh
mais euh leur situation euh dans les
hôpitaux euh est aujourd'hui euh
catastrophique que ce soit en terme de
soignant euh alors alors ça ça dépend
des pays sur est-ce que c'est d'abord
les infirmières qui manquent ou les
médecins comme en France ça dépend des
régions où il y a des endroits où c'est
plus les médecins notre plus les les
infirmières mais le vieillissement de la
population les maladies chroniques et
puis je le disais le progrès tout
simplement je on on on détecte
aujourd'hui des pathologies qu'on ne
qu'on ne détectait pas voilà qu'on ne
détectait pas et tant mieux sur où il y
a des pathologies aujourd'hui on est si
on regardarde la progression sur les
cancers pédiatriques aujourd'hui il y en
a 20 % sur lesquels on n arrive toujours
pas il y en a 80 % et c'est en quelques
années qu'on a trouvé des traitements
pour 80 % des des cancers pqu sur le
cancer du sein les progrès sont sont
inouï donc la dépense elle elle va
continuer à progresser et vous avez
raison c'est j'ai cru entendre la
première ministre parce qu'elle me dit
ça progresse et comment ça se fait que
les gens soient pas contents je je je je
je je j'aiessayé du du reste de
l'expliquer hier moi je je je crois que
notre système pardon de ce de ce de ce
d'utiliser ces termes il
est on a tendance je le dis comme ça et
pardon de le dire ainsi de à toujours
dire qu'il est au sol à terre par terre
que tout ve que tout est terrifiant il y
a des endroits objectivement où c'est
désers médicaux où on n arrive pas et
cetera et
simultanément dans c'est quelquefois
dans ces mêmes territoires il y a des
initiatives des choses qui se font de la
coopération qui est inoui je veux dire
je prends
l'exemple du 18e arrondissement à la
fois on a on est dans un désert médical
ça n'a pas d'autres nom et à la fois on
a une CPTs qui fait le lien avec
l'hôpital Claude Bernard de La php dans
des modalités de enfin je dis ça pour
Anne et Bernard qui connaissent ça par
cœur euh et et je vois ça j'ai vu ça en
Dordogne quand je suis allé dans le
Tarne il y a des endroits exceptionnels
et puis il y a des il y a des progrès
exceptionnels il y a des progrès
exceptionnels qui nous coûtent de plus
en plus cher mais vous allez à l'IGR à
Gustave rousi sur l'interception des
cancers c'est c'est c'est vous sortez de
là je je le dis sans faire de de trémolo
mais avec les vous dites les larmes aux
yeux sur ce qu'on éétait pas capable de
faire du coup pour moi à la fin et c'est
pour ça que je je reviens
dessus le seul critère de soutenabilité
financière de notre système à moyen
terme c'est de prendre pour de vrai le
virage de la prévention pour de vrai
c'est-à-dire que la prévention c'est pas
juste manger bouger ou marcher et cetera
euh je dis ça pour moi c'est c'est aussi
mettre dans la tête de tout le monde en
France que en fait
euh ce truc sur lequel tous les
ministres de la santé les uns après les
les autres se sont vterés quand ils ont
voulu formuler le truc en fait pour pour
que l'hôpital aille mieux il vaut mieux
qu'il y ait moins de malade qui arrive
donc ça évidemment tous ont cette phrase
qui leur colle à la peau mais la réalité
elle est quand même qu'aujourd'hui nos
dispositifs de prévention de médecine
personnalisée de médecine prédictive
d'intelligence artificielle sont dingu
donc par exemple moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
obtenu que dans France 2030 qui finance
voilà qui finance beaucoup de notamment
la décarbonation d'une partie de notre
industrie on est une nouvelle ligne qui
soit sur l'investissement en prévention
en santé qui va être de l'ordre de 350
millions d'euros pour aller parce qu'on
est on est très bon par ailleurs en
France là-dessus simplement c'est
d'autres que d'autres pays qui achètent
ces ces produits d' je pense moi que le
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est
structurel c'est pas c'est pas juste à
court terme le bfortus qui nous permet
de franchir peut-être un peu mieux la
bronque Olite c'est quelque chose de de
de beaucoup plus structurel
aujourd'hui vous le savez moi je l'ai
dit je j'enis toujours les les les les
gens qui sont morts du covid en sain sa
ils sont morts
d'obésité ils sont morts d'obésité ils
sont morts de déterminants sociau de
santé ils sont ils sont ils sont ceux
qui étaient en RA parce que
malheureusement les personnes les plus
âgées sont souvent mortes dans les
épades voilà ils sont morts d'obésité
donc comment on traite l'obésité ben il
y a de la prévention
primaire plus classique sur laquelle on
est en retard on est en retard sur la
recherche en prévention et puis il y a
des progrès thérapeutiques sur le
traitement de l'obésité bon et je pense
que ce sujet-l sur les comorbidités sur
c'est un sujet majeur qui est devant
nous donc pour moi évidemment je peux
pas être satisfait de vous présenter un
budget qui est en en déséquilibre de 9
milliards voilà avec une perspective à
moyen terme d'être plutôt autour de 17
que de que de que de que que de que de
neuf hein euh mais je pense que
l'investissement c'est pour ça que je le
qualifie d'investissement dans la
prévention il est le seul dans une
population vieillissante avec des
maladies chroniques avec des avec le
réchauffement climatique et tout ce qui
va aller avec il est le seul qui nous
permet de de tenir voilà donc c'est
c'est comme ça que je vous réponds sans
pouvoir vous chiffrer ce que ça veut
dire mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
il faut que aussi pardon je m'arrête
après monsieur le Président nos
dispositifs de pr de
financement suivent ces évolutions
thérapeutiques je prends l'exemple de du
cancer du sein aujourd'hui à Gustave
roussi il s'ils interceptent un cancer
ils font venir une femme 5 jours
d'affilé et après c'est terminé si je
puis dire le traitement est fini ça leur
rapporte entre guillemets beaucoup moins
que trois fois 4 4 jours de de chimio et
nous il faut que notre agilité de tarif
suive ces ces évolution là aujourd'hui
on on y est pas aujourd'hui ils font ça
à perte voilà donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on doit bouger pardon j'ai j'ai pas
fait 4 He mais presque très bien merci
beaucoup alors je vais donner la parole
donc il y a il y a h demandes
d'intervention un aminon
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour les
réponses détaillées que que vous nous
faites et pour le vos propos merci pour
les
répesé
mais c'est pour ça que je disais
monsieur le ministre je voulais revenir
d'abord sur une boutagne que faisait
Alain Vassel qui était le rapporteur
général avant Jean-Marie van leenberg et
Elisabeth douanau il faisait la même
comparaison que vous par rapport au
déficit de la Sécurité sociale déficit
de l'État et alamacelle disait dans ces
conditions il vaudrait mieux supprimer
Bery je sais pas si vous allez jusque là
et faire gérer le budget d'État en
gestion paritaire comme pour la sécurité
sociale je ferme la parenthèse et j'en
viiens à mes questions
bien sûr bien sûr euh je voudrais vous
dire donc évidemment comme tous mes
collègues je suis très inquiet par par
par l'évolution du financement de la
sécurité sociale et de la santé en
France et avec certains de mes collègues
je suis très inquiet aussi par rapport à
la financiérisation de la santé mais ça
on en parlera dans le cadre de du du
débat en séance mes questions vont
porter plutôt monsieur le ministre sur
l'innovation
elles sont dans le domaine de la santé
elles évoluent évidemment vous l'avez
dit à un rythme S
elle constitue pour les malades un
espoir pour ceux qui sont pris en charge
les malades dans le cadre de
l'innovation sont pas toujours bien pris
en charge la médecine de demain donc va
combiner vous le savez des des
technologies de pointe la biologie
synthétique l'intelligence artificielle
les jumeaux numériques pour apporter aux
patients évidemment des solutions
personnalisées préventives et
prédictives la France donc est reconnue
dans ce domaine depuis longtemps pour la
qualité de sa recherche en santé vous
l'avez dit et pour sa capacité à assurer
une mise à disposition rapide des
innovations il y a eu les atu il y a
aussi l'accès précoce maintenant
toutefois les mécanismes existant
d'accès
euh aux innovations ont été mis en place
au fil du temps et elles sont ils sont
perçu comme hétérogène et
particulièrement complexe du point de
vue des porteurs de projets innovants
quelle est donc votre analyse de la
situation et pensez-vous que ces
dispositifs sont suffisamment adaptés
aux innovations qui combinent de plus en
plus plusieurs technologies
ma deuxième question concerne la la
mesure relative aux actes
uniquement donc je me répète mais la
France est reconnu depuis de nombreuses
années pour sa capacité à innover en
santé à développer des solutions
innovantes au bénéfice des passant parmi
ces solutions la chirurgie constitue un
parfait exemple de l'excellence
française c'est un de mes amis
professeur de chirurgie à Amien qui m'a
demandé de vous poser cette question il
y a eu la première greffe à Amien la
greffe du visage en 5 il y a eu
récemment en 2021 par exemple le premier
curage d' bois ortique à Saint-Étienne
le système d'évaluation actuel n'est pas
adapté au rythme de diffusion des
innovations en outre le forfait
innovation qui a été mis en place en
2015 et après 10 ans de recul à peu près
10 ans ne paraît pas comme l'outil
adapté pour accélérer l'accès aux
innovations en effet à ce jour 16
technologies de santé seulement ont fait
l'objet d'un avis favorable de la Haute
Autorité de Santé en 10 ans par ailleurs
le temps d'instruction et les délais de
mise en œuvre rendent le dispositif peu
attractif et vous le savez très bien
alors je vais aller directement à ma
question pour ne pas être long que
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
amorcer un réel changement et permettre
un accès plus rapide des actes innovants
au bénéfice du patient tout en assurant
et c'est là le point important une
traçabilité de ces actes en encadrant la
tarification qui n'est pas encadrée
actuellement et en recueillant les
données en vue de le évaluation dans le
droit commun
ouis merci beaucoup je donne la parole à
jean-marieberg micro il fonctionnait pas
bon pardon je vous ai écouté
attentivement et j'ai des questions mais
en même temps peut-être des pistes
pour réaliser quelques économies je
pense notamment et vous l'avez évoqué
euh au fraude à la à l'assurance maladie
les fraudes ou des erreurs d'ailleurs
des anomalies elles sont nombreuses et
l'évaluation l'estimation tarde euh
c'est plusieurs ça fait plusieurs je
dirais plusieurs années que nous les
sollicitons et au moins 2 ans et on a
toujours pas les résultats totaux de ces
estimations on peut pas faire une une
évaluation correcte et puis surtout une
intervention sur les fraudes et les
fraudeurs si on n pas cette estimation
or je dirais la CNAM est très en retard
par rapport aux autres caisses donc je
vous demande il y a des lettres de
missions qui ont été je
dirais donné par déjà quand c'était
monsieur dusop et puis votre à l'époque
je ne sais plus qui était qui était
c'était madame Buzin peut-être encore
il faut aller plus vite il faut aller
plus vite parce que il y a environ 5 6
milliards c'est la Cour des comptes qui
le dit euh à récupérer dans ce domaine
euh d'autre part on l'a évoqué vous
l'avez évoqué aussi il y a les soins euh
redondants les actes redondants et
inutiles dans certaines disciplines
médicales pense à la radiologie la
biologie euh c'est pas seulement de la
faute je dirais
la cause d'un d'un médecin mais plutôt
d'un parcours vous allez chez un votre
médecin généraliste qui vous dit faire
une radio vous allez voir le spécialiste
parce qu'il vous a dit après il faut
aller voir le spécialiste et on fait une
radio et puis après vous allez à
l'hôpital et on fait une radio et cetera
et cetera je dis pitié l'assurance
maladie n'a pas
effectivement le devoir de régler les
des problèmes qui sont souvent on nous
dit des problèmes de
compéten enfin de voilà on a
effectivement des laboratoires ou des
agences quand c'est laboratoir quand
c'est la biologie des cabinés de
radiologie qui sont plus ou moins je
dirais compétents aux yeux de tel tel
tel médecin ou tel hôpital donc il y a
un problème à régler à ce niveau-là
c'est 25 % 25 % selon l'évaluation de
l'OCDE
c'est repris par tous les ministres de
la santé avant vous donc je crois qu'il
y a là aussi une source d'économie
importante et dernier
point on a parlé de
l'hôpital
l'hôpital j'ai eu
l'occasion quelquesuns quelques-uns ici
peut-être à nous en souvenir aussi on a
vu l'hôpital de La de Valencienne on a
eu une une audition du directeur de cet
hôpital je dois dire que le management
de l'hôpital dans les règles actuelles
permet de fonctionner beaucoup
mieux de ne pas avoir de pénurie de
personnel et d'être à l'équilibre
financièrement je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez l'hôpital de Valencienne mais
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez le
visiter puis puissiez effectivement en
terme de bonne pratique essayer de de le
recommander à tous ses confrères voilà
je aller beaucoup plus loin monsieur le
Président c'est parfait Olivier oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je reviens sur le le déficit du
du PLFSS des 9 milliards ou 17 milliards
et vous avez avec un trait d'humour au
fond évoqué euh et relativiser ce ce
déficit sauf que certes hein je moi je
ne me résou pas à ce qu'on est euh notre
système de protection sociale en
déficite parce que qu'on le veuille ou
non on reporte sur les générations
futures son financement et d'un strict
point de vue moral au fondin ça ne me
paraît pas
extrêmement vertueux ni même responsable
et peut-être d'ailleurs serons-nous
jugés sévèrement sur ces questions à à
l'avenir
mais plutôt une perspective sur la
régulation la réponse que vous avez
formulée est intéressante hein sur la
prévention mais ça veut dire quand même
que vous préconisez euh une solution qui
qui résulterait par un changement des
comportements et que vous n'envisagez
pas ou envisagez-vous des des des des
changements structurels pour cette
régulation et à ce moment-là lesquels et
et et puis envisagez-vous aussi euh de
des des augmentations de recettes et à
ce moment là lesquell pour se mettre
dans une perspective de de régulation et
donc ça c'est une question à portée plus
générale et une question à porter plus
précise euh pensez-vous qu'aujourd'hui
on forme assez de médecins dans notre
pays on a eu ces débats ces jours
derniers sur la question de de la
pénurie on est passé du numérus closus
au numérus apertus et si vous pensez
qu'il faut encore augmenter le nombre de
médecins formés comment envisagez-vous
le de le faire et quel dialogue avec les
doyens des facultés pour augmenter ce
nombre de médecins formés je vous
remercie merci merci Bernard
jemier merci monsieur le Président je
commencerai comme Olivier je m'étonnais
d'ailleurs que aucun de mes collègues
jusqu'à ce qu'Olivier h soulève la
question ne soulève cette question de la
soutenabilité et on partage complètement
votre souci sur cette question de la
soutenabilité de la sécurité sociale
mais quelle soutenabilité quand vous
rejeter sur les 5 années à venir un
déficit même croissant et pour
nous
c'est un c'est une question qui est
première ce choix politique car c'est un
choix politique nous estimons de mettre
la sécurité sociale en
déficit il y a quelques années de 3 ans
après la crise sanitaire cette
commission et cette hémicycle ont rejeté
euh la proposition du gouvernement qui a
tout de même qui a rentré en vigueur de
transférer plus de 150 milliards d'euros
de dette à la cadèe chaque année la
sécurité sociale est privée de 10
milliards
si cette mesure n'avait pas été prise
déjà elle sera à l'équilibre et je vais
m'arrêter là parce que il y a les
questions que soulève olivierau des
recettes et cetera mais la conséquence
de ce choix du déficit c'est qu'en
permanence la question est évidemment de
réguler les dépenses je ne dis pas nous
ne disons pas qu'il faut pas réger les
dépenses et je vais venir mais en tout
état de cause ce qui est projeté
aussi en direction du pays et vous
pourrez peut-être le dire à la première
ministre qui s'en souci c'est que notre
population n'est pas contente parce que
elle voit un système qui en permanence
est en déficit et les gens en plus
n'arrivent plus à accéder au soins alors
ils ont des bonnes raisons de pas être
contents c'est d'autant plus inquiétant
et c'est ma première question qu'il y a
un décalage entre ces données
financières et les résultats du système
un système de santé ça sert à quoi au
fond ça sert à faire progresser nos
indicateurs de santé les deux principaux
indicateurs de santé d'un pays c'est la
mortalité infantile et nous sommes en
train de glisser au milieu du classement
et c'est l'espérance de vie à la
naissance pour laquelle notre pays a été
très longtemps à la première ou à la
2uxème place au monde et où nous venons
de glisser c'est dans les documents de
votre ministère de la 6e à la 13e place
des pays de l'OCDE 13e place des pays de
l'OCDE pour l'espérance de vie à la
naissance alors un système de santé qui
produit de tels
résultats il y a un décalage voilà donc
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur cette
question vous avez soulevé à raison la
question de la pertinence euh la
première ministre de la Santé du chef de
l'État niès
Busin portait très fortement cette
question
euh 20 à 30 % d'actes inutile et cetera
ce matin juste avant de venir à cette
audition moi j'étais avec avec une
organisation importante de praticiens
hospitaliers qui disait que il pensent
que ce chiffre est exact pour les soins
hospitaliers et ils ont précisé y
compris en chirurgie en oncologie j'
refait préciser c'est tout de même assez
inquiétant mais au fond peut-on faire la
pertinence des soins quand on a un
système de financement qui favorise
l'acte ou l'activité enfin l'activité à
l'hôpital l'acte dans le secteur
ambulatoire peut-on faire la pertinence
des soins quand la financiarisation est
en train de se développer à vitesse
galopante ma troisème question porte sur
la
prévention vous avez cité un certain
nombre vous mettez l'accient sur cette
question et n partageons tous votre
souci et votre volontarisme en la
matière mais j'ai j'ai le sentiment que
vous portez beaucoup la prévention
médicalisée des dispositifs alors je
vous donne une LFSS r pas tout hein
soyons clair et vous êtes en début de de
fonction c'est pas un reproche mais moi
je me référerai volontiers on a deux
collègues députés Cyril Isaac sibil éc
Barz qui ont fait un rapport très
intéressant sur cette question juste
avant l'été et qui disent bien que si on
veut une véritable politique de
prévention elle doit porter sur les
déterminants et or dans notre pays à la
fois notre notre dispositif on va dire
organisationnel d'État en la matière est
désorganisé et faible nous avion fait
avec Florence l sarade un rapport
d'ailleurs sur cette question il y a il
y a 2 ans et par ailleurs l'autree c'est
qui doit doit s'adresser à la jeunesse
et beaucoup effectivement ce sont en
particulier les points que soulevait
Élisabeth doano sur les comportements et
puis ma dernière question elle ne porte
pas sur le pfss mais elle se porte sur
une question importante qui arrive en
débat la semaine prochaine et qui vont
concerne au premier rang comme ministre
de la Santé de la prévention dans cette
assemblée va être étudié un texte qui
prévoit de mettre fin au dispositif
d'aide médical état nous sommes
évidemment totalement opposés pour notre
part à cette hypothèse là quelle est
votre position en tant que ministre de
la santé et de la prévention je vous
remercie merci Monsieur jier J'ai encore
quatre intervenants je prends toutes les
questions ou vous vou les faire une
pause déjà com vous voulez non non pe
alors on continue jusine guidise
oui merci Monsieur le le Président
Monsieur le ministre euh moi je vais
aller à l'essentiel parce que c'est vrai
qu'on il est déjà tard donc je vais vous
poser qu'une seule question et pourtant
j'en auraai beaucoup sur les TND voilà
l'article 38 euh au niveau du du PLFSS
ne traite que les enfants de 0 à 6 ans
qu'est-ce que l'on fait pour un enfant
qui aura 4 ans enfin qui a 4 ans
aujourd'hui et qui aura 7 ans au moment
où ce dispositif sera mis en vigueur ça
sera trop tard pour lui que
proposez-vous pour ses enfants les frais
pour les 06 ans sont remboursés de
manière forfaitaire une partie prise en
charge par l'Assurance Maladie une
partie par les mutuels que font que
faisons-nous de ceux qui n'ont pas de
mutuel et voilà je pourrais vous poser
plein d'autres questions comme ça mais
franchement je suis un peu inquiète donc
on a fait un rapport avec mon collègue
Burgoa et et Madame Ferré on a soulevé
pas mal de de de sujets par rapport à ça
mais je vais m'arrêter là parce que je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
questions après merci
Céline merci président monsieur le
ministre vous avez beaucoup évoqué la
prévention et d'ailleurs vous êtes
ministre de la sé et de la prévention ce
qui est une très bonne chose mais et
vous l'avez implicitement dit la
prévention est souvent imp ponsif on en
parle beaucoup tout le monde de bon sens
se dit que c'est dans cette voie
évidemment qu'il faut s'engager il se
passe en réalité pas grand-chose là vous
avez évoqué ça avec force mais on voit
pas non plus alors effectivement tout va
pas se faire en une noix de finance et
vous avez pris vos fonctions récemment
mais je ne vois pas le début but d'un
d'une stratégie d'un plan qui
permettrait de constater qu'on a
vraiment changé de paradigme par rapport
à
ça deuxième
chose je rejoins complètement les propos
de la rapporteur Corine Ambert sur les
les raisons qui expliquent
l'accroissement des indemnités
journalières qui sont d'ordre divers
mais en tout cas qui sont pas d'abord je
pense le fait des ition anormale des
médecins on a beaucoup ces derniers
jours dans le débat sur la PPL Valtou
évoquer le fait qu'il fallait un peu
coucounner les médecins parce que ils
étaient dans une situation compliquée
est-ce que vous pensez que faire
contrôler les prescriptions de médecins
par des médecins eux-mêmes missionnés je
vais le dire comme ça par les employeurs
c'est de nature
à renforcer la confiance avec ses
praticiens
enfin est-ce que vous mesurez je sais
pas je le dis comme ça mais sans
jugement de valeur bien évidemment
l'effet que peut faire dans la dans une
population
qui pour un tiers d'entre elles renonce
à se soigner qui pour un tiers d'entre
elles a dû faire face à des pénuries de
médicaments de dire qu'il y a une
explosion des dépenses et que donc il va
falloir se serrer la ceinture est-ce que
vous mesurez l'effet social je dirais
même politique de ce genre de message
qui peut paraître complètement à côté
pour la plupart de nos concitoyens et
enfin euh question peut-être un peu
provocatrice à quoi va servir ce débat
sur le PLFSS 2024 notamment ici au Sénat
on voit que l'OND d'â notamment mais pas
que a été rejeté y compris en commission
des affaires sociales à l'Assemblée le
493 a été activé dès hier soir
on entend qu'il y a des choses qui ne
seraient plus dans le l' FSS mais qui
pourrai venir par d'autres vecteurs
comme les déremboursements enfin ou
l'augmentation des franchises
médicales pour la sincérité et la
loyauté de nos débats est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer y compris et je le
dis sans naïveté est-ce que vous avez
des marges de manœuvre par exemple sur
l'ondâ qui est rejeté plus de manière
plus importante que les années
précédentes est-ce qu'il y a des marges
de manœuvre et est-ce que le débat que
nous allons mener ici peut avoir un
effet merci merci beaucoup Émilienne
pourirol voà merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Bernard Jomier a
dit l'essentiel de ce que j'aurais pu
souhaiter dire je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier sur vos propositions de
travail parce qu'effectivement le venir
qu' moment du PLFSS et vous voyez ce
matin même si on se donne 2 heur ou même
si on en prenait trois euh on serait en
train de refaire tout le débat qu'on va
avoir dans quelques jours et
donc proposer de nous rencontrer et et
je le vois comme une marque de
considération pour le par pour le
Parlement et en cé temps difficile
reconnaître le
rôle travail je pardon euh je voulais
moi parler essentiellement du médicament
et de l'innovation médicament tout en
faisant une parenthèse sur la prévention
effectivement on sait bien que c'est un
investissement dans l'immédiat et comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure le
résultat sera en
2050 mais on avait travaillé avec notre
collègue
écolo Mélan Vogel sur fait un rapport
sur la sécurité sociale écologique du
21e siècle qui est centré sur la
prévention et qui montre combien en fait
la prévention c'est dans toutes nos
politiques publiques qu'elle devrait
être intégrée aujourd'hui on sait bien
que le plan le plan national de santé
environnementale il fonctionne en silo
chaque ministère fait son petit truc
mais il y a jamais de j'allais dire de
cohérence entre les différents
ministères je crois que ça serait
important sur les médicaments sur
l'innovation est-ce que vous pourriez n
nous préciser un petit peu comment on
peut arriver à avoir des prix aussi et
alors je sais bien on nous on nous
euh sert chaque fois le secret des
affaires et c'est le CPS et cetera et
mais je distingue bien la différence
entre les produits matures et le
problème de leur prix même si c'est
qu'un facteur aggravant hein la pénurie
qui est pas qui en est pas la cause
puisque en Suisse ou en Allemagne les
prix des génériques sont plus élevés et
ils ont aussi des problèmes de pénurie
des Big Pharma et les produits innovants
en particulier dans les thérapies
hygiéniques comment peut-on justifier
aujourd'hui je sais bien que ça du les
hospitalisations que l'espoir de vie et
cetera et cetera mais comment peut-on
justifier des des prix qui sont à 1
million d'euros la
[Musique]
dose en particulier dans les thérapies
géniques et comment peut-on le contrôler
comment peut-on le contrôler aujourd'hui
il n'y a aucune transparence sur les
prix c'est le secret des affaires ces
médicaments innovants sont souvent issu
de recherche publique ou par publuique
je pense en
particulier à la recherche issue du
Téléton qui a permis d'avancé dans une
thérapiegénique et qui a été parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le moyen de développer
la production du médicament ça a été
racheté et du coup effectivement le
traitement est à 1 million d'euros la
dose alors que le laboratoire qui
bénéficie aujourd'hui du 100 million
d'euros la dose lui n'a fait aucun
effort dans la recherche donc voilà moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait une avancée
sur la trans transparence de ces prix en
particulier ces médicaments innovants
parce que vous l'avez dit ça va très
vite on en a de plus en plus et tant
mieux he c'est un gros progrès pour pour
pour notre médecine mais ça va devenir
avec leissement de la population et tout
ce que vous avez pu dire et que nous on
a tous pu dire ça va devenir
insoutenable pour la sécurité sociale si
on a des prix pareils on est loin des
2,30 € de la boîte de dolipran merci sur
le médicament d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup
de questions sur la R aussi partie aussi
des enjeux Pascal gr pour terminer oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je voudrais revenir sur le
le transfert de d'un peu plus de 1
milliard d'euros et le prélèvement
plutôt sur la branche
ATMP parce qu'on parle prévention et et
finalement est-ce qu'il serait pas
plutôt judicieux de laisser cette argent
à l'entreprise ça leur appartient
d'ailleurs et qui puisse faire davantage
de prévention on a énormément de de
besoins des établissements
médicaux-sociaux la branche la branche
la filière du bâtiment aussi qui a qui a
beaucoup de progrès à faire et puis
aussi toutes ces petites entreprises qui
n'ont pas les structures et que la
Carsat pourrait aider justement pour
pour avoir des projets et améliorer
ainsi et diminuer le nombre d'accients
du travail voire de de maladies
professionnelles alors chaque année bien
sûr l'argument c'est la sous-
dééclaration des accidents et maladies
professionnelles mais là-dessus informer
les médecins je je je le dis chaque
année informeer mieux les médecins pour
que ce soit fait mais en tout cas cet
argent là il est indispensable tous les
collègues ont parlé de la prévention
alors peut-être pas celle qui est faite
dans dans l'entreprise mais c'est la
même chose parce que après c'est la
santé publique de toute façon donc on en
a vraiment besoin aujourd'hui moi je ne
suis plus rapporteur sur cette branche
c'est ma collègue Mariepierre Richet
mais moi je viens du monde de
l'entreprise je vous ass sûr que quand
on fait des efforts financiers mais
aussi d'information auprès des salariés
et des entreprises on a véritablement
des résultats et travailler avec la
médecine du travail ce serait très bien
aussi médecin médecine du travail on a
des attentes moi j'étais rapporteur sur
le dernier texte c'est pas encore
complètement avancé quel dommage quel
dommage mais comme l'a dit Émilienne
pomérol de manière très sympathique en
fait la préventionour sur investissement
l'aura pas donc pour les élections ça ne
joue pas donc c'est pas intéressant
merci merci merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
je sur la prévention d'abord alors je
c'est plus risqué parce que je je
vais je répondrai après parce que comme
Madame comme
Madame non madame Brulin c'est ça est
sorti c'est ça est sorti et que elle m'a
elle m'a dit qu'il y avait pas de
d'ambition j'attends qu'elle revienne
donc je prends je prends dans
l'ordre président Milon vous vous
l'évoquez sur l'accès précoce moi j'ai
je je
je mon prédécesseur avait
demandé une exper globale et notamment
les éléandes de benchmark pour parler en
bon français avec ce qui se passe dans
les pays étrangers pour savoir pourquoi
on a ce reproche persistant de de la
vitesse
d'autorisation voilà même si on a des
dispositifs de de secours si je puis
dire sur le les dispositifs dit
compassionnel ou si par ailleurs il y a
dans le PLFSS des mesures d'amélioration
moi j'aurais le le retour au premier
trimestre 2024 à ce stade je ne me pour
dire les choses pardon je je je ne me
sens pas outillé pour réformer la
totalité de l'accès précoce ce que je
peux dire quand même c'est que des
discussions très très directes que j'ai
eu avec le président de la
hasas professeur
colollet il est tout à fait conscient
lui aussi
euh de la nécessité de de de de de se de
ce calendrier y compris de pouvoir euh
s'appuyer sur des études qui ont été
faites par d'autres agences euh voilà
quand elles ont été faites seulement les
mêmes critères que nous donc je pense
qu'on a un chantier accès précosse qui
est pour dire les choses par rapport à
tout à l'heure euh qui est moins euh la
vision tiersmondistes que les
laboratoires essaient de faire passer
autour de l'idée qu'on aurait accès à
aucun médicament innovant mais on a
quand même un sujet euh de délai
d'autorisation donc ce chantier il est
devant nous pour euh pour l'année qui
vient et j'attends euh le rapport en 24
aujourd'hui euh je ne je ne je ne l'ai
pas donc je je suis pas enfin je ne peux
pas vous vous je suis pas capable d'en
dire plus sinon je dirais des des des
bêtises voilà sur euh
euh mais c'est un peu la même chose je
pense avoir en partie répondu sur le le
fait de dire que effectivement euh on
doit voir une une agilité dans la
tarification qui suive les innovations
d'une certaine manière et ça pour
l'instant on l'a pas donc pareil c'est
une réforme un peu un peu
systémique sur le système
d'évaluation de la chirurgie je partage
avec votre collègue d'Amien et quand on
me dit un professeur à Amien évidemment
pour ma pour ma survie je fais toujours
attention mais euh je je suis d'accord
avec vous dans les deux sens
c'est-à-dire qui compris enfin sans sans
trahir de secret mais il y a quelquefois
euh des hôpitaux qui qui ont acheté par
exemple des robots chirurgicaux euh pour
attirer et pour donner de l'attractivité
voilà dont on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont absolument non pertinent sur
certaines prise en charge de pathologie
donc c'est c'est ce que je voulais
évoquer aussi tout à l'heure en disant
que au-delà du médicament l'évaluation
dans la durée de la pertinence des des
des des compris des achats et de la et
de l'utilisation de tel ou tel de tel ou
tel matériel est un point qui est pour
moi qui est pour moi important il y a
pas de il y a pas de de doute le le sur
ce que
disait sénateur van lerenberg je je vous
avez raison et je je pense qu'on est en
train notamment
enfin dit
autrement la réouverture de la
négociation conventionnelle je fais un
détour pour répondre à votre question et
pour moi aussi le
moyen que se banalise le fait que
l'assurance maladie quand elle repère
des actes redondants et cetera puisse se
retourner vers les médecins en leur
disant il y a quelque chose qui ne
marche pas il y a quelque chose qui ne
va pas et le rythme par exemple de
versement de de nouveaux documents sur
le DMP qui est passé entre 12 et 15
millions par mois de nouveaux documents
qui sont versé fait que je pense que on
a un outil qui en routine on y est pas
encore pourra être utile là-dessus après
il y a un point que vous avez évoqué qui
est celui de l'osto où on a le côté on
refait tout parce que par ailleurs on a
plus confiance
dans le radiologue de l'osto le et
cetera ça c'est un sujet aussi de bonnes
pratiques et c'est pour ça que quand
j'évoque dans le PLFSS et quand je
j'assume de dire qu'il y a aussi des
sujets d'efficience il y en a aussi
là-dessus sur les actes redondants mais
c'est c'est c'est deux morceaux
différents je pense que le
DMP va nous faire progresser je pense
aussi que les la responsabilisation des
personnes enfin que le médecin il doit
entendre quand le patient lui dit mais
j'ai l'impression d'avoir déjà fait cet
examen le nombre de fois où vous enfin
je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
moi j'ai l'impression de l'avoir dit euh
souvent
même si aujourd'hui quand je le dis les
gens me disent que mais c'est justement
parce que je suis devenu ministre qu'il
faut le faire deux fois donc donc je
pense que le que le que le que le c'est
très important et que là là aussi c'est
là que l'innovation va jouer enfin je le
dis très clairement si je sais pas si
certains connaissent je prends un
exemple la Clinique Pasteur à
Toulouse l'utilisation je je me tournais
vers vous vous l'avez compris
l'utilisation de le de des des des des
systèmes d'information et de
l'intelligence artificielle pour ne pas
refaire deux fois les mêmes examens pour
bénéficier est impressionnante et du
coup elle a un impact direct pardon de
le dire ainsi sur la viabilité et la
rentabilité de l'établissement et la
qualité de la prise en charge du patient
euh accessoirement donc donc je je sais
pas si c'est je j'iraai bien volontiers
à l'hôpital de de Valencienne que je ne
connais pas euh euh je ne suis jamais
aller à Valencienne je dois le confesser
euh ça ouais voilà donc je je je je
voilà je me considère je ne considère
pas pardon parce que je crois que le le
sénateur etau et et et Bernard jourmier
l'ont tous les deux dit euh et donc
c'est que je me suis mal exprimé moi je
prends pas le la cible à 17 milliards de
déficit comme un acquis moi je suis euh
aussi euh
ministre des comptes sociaux en ce que
je le dis je le dis comme ça en ce que
si notre système socialisé d'assurance
maladie ne tient pas ben
d'autres acteurs privés viendront
prendre sa place donc je suis pour ça
c'est pour ça que je me que je suis très
engagé dans dans ce
sujet-là et que je le je le je le
considère Essen ci
euh et que donc quand je s'il y avait
une ambiguïé je vous souhaite la lever
euh le travail qu'on va faire c'est que
le 17 milliards que j'évoqué pour être
transparent sur le fait de des
projections je je je considère pas que
ça puisse être possible qu'on se dise ah
benah tiens on va doubler le déficit
euh dans le dans la période qui s'ouvre
il faut qu'on trouve comment on le
maîtrise mais après je je je reviendrai
à d'autres questions sur justement
qu'est-ce qui est maîtrisable et
qu'est-ce qui ne l' pas euh est-ce qu'il
y a
euh assez je je sur les infirmières
alors ça dépend aussi des territoires je
pense que le protocole qui a été signé
en son temps par Jean Castex avec région
de France moi j'ai tenu la semaine
dernière le le le comité de pilotage
Ctait Marie GUID Duffet qui représentait
région de
France pour progresser je crois qu'on a
levé aujourd'hui toute une partie des
des incompréhensions sur les chiffres de
départ sur l'investissement dans les is
donc on a on a plus 17 % d'infirmières
qui sortent chaque année on a ce sujet
majeur de la comment on dit de la
réingénierie du parcours parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'infirmière de jeunes
d'étudiantes qui quittent en cours de
formation parce que c'est trop dur ça
correspond pas donc il faut et ou sinon
c'est trop loin alors que même dans
parcours sup il y a une on pourra avoir
une préférence géographique mais qui
souvent n'est pas cliqué donc on doit
travailler là-dessus il y a pas de sujet
je pense que sur les infirmières on est
sur la bonne voie sur les médecins il
faut se parler euh Franco hein je le dis
on a on a beaucoup plus de médecins en
formation que ce qu'on avait le le ceux
qui disent qu'on en a pas plus on en a
nettement plus mais alors je sais pas et
sans doute pas autour de la table mais
simultanément moi dans le secret de mon
bureau certains de me dire faisons gaffe
quand même parce que avec avec justement
l'intelligence artificielle et cetera
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'on aura besoin
de radiologue ou de dermatologue dans 20
ans c'est le même raisonnement qui avait
conduit au numérus closus il y a 30 ans
donc moi je me je me je pense qu'il y
aura toujours besoin de médecin que il y
a eu une petite il y a eu un délai
d'ajustement de
l'université pour pour se mettre en
situation de former mais je pense que
dans la période ce qui me préoccupe le
le plus je dois dire moi c'est la la
pénurie enfin la pénurie la baisse des
étudiants en pharma en
pharmacie gros gros sujet parce que
parce que sur notre offre de soins ça va
être un gros sujet la la la difficulté à
sortir pardon mais vous savez tous que
dans l'osto il y a une fonction qui est
clé même si personne n'en parle jamais
le manip radio euh impossible de tenir
une promo un un/ers seulement arrive au
bout de ces 3 ans de formation euh voilà
donc on a là-dessus je pense qu'il faut
qu'on se il y a les médecins mais il
faut pas il faut qu'on fasse gaffe à pas
oublier les autres professions dans
lesquelles
euh dans lesquelles il faut qu'on soit
qu'on maintiennent l'attractivité
euh Bernard jaumier disait euh enfin je
je me
euh non enfin en tout cas non je ne
crois pas qu'on ait fait le le choix du
déficit de la Sécurité sociale en tout
cas moi je ne fais pas ce choix après je
pour être très clair je je disons deux
choses simultanées qui vont faire du du
célèbre en même temps il y a une partie
des
exonération de ctisation qui pèse
évidemment sur les ressources de la
sécurité sociale je crois mais je peux
me planter mais et j'ai évolué c'est
pas ici que je vais le dire vous
connaissez tous sans doute mon parcours
j'ai évolué là-dessus je crois qu'une
partie de ces exonérations ont permis
parallèlement ben la baisse du chômage
et des éléments de de retour sur ce qui
permet de financer notre modèle social
c'est le débat qu'on peut avoir je pense
c'est un débat de fond hein qu'on peut
avoir on a fait cette année un mouvement
qui n'a pas été évooqué ici qui est très
important malgré tout c'est qu'on a
Thomas CASNAV présenter vous en
reparlerez sans noute dans la partie 1
et 2 on va on va bouger sur le bandeau
famille qui était une exonération voilà
donc c'est un point qui me semble
important alors on va pas aller jusqu'à
2 milliards mais déjà cette année ça
sera 650 millions d'euros puisqu'on va
gelé et on va passer en franc enfin en
franc décidément le type type eff frais
on va passer en euros et pas et pas
voilà c'est une exonération qui pèse qui
pèse qui qui qui pesait exactement sur
les sur les salaires sur des salaires
qui étaient assez élevés mais c'était
une demande beaucoup de l'industrie mais
aujourd'hui le sujet n'est plus
l'attractivité des emplois industriels
donc il y aura des il y aura des
éléments et après moi je je je je je me
battrai comme un chien pour la la la
compensation les compensation quand on
fait peser sur la sécurité sociale une
de mes plus grandes tristesses dans la
vie professionnelle et politique c'est
quand j'ai quitté la j'étais directeur
adjoint du cabinet de de Bernard
Caseneuve en 2017 et la sécurité sociale
était à enfin la branche maladie il y a
400 millions d'euros de l'équilibre qui
correspondait exactement à un déficit de
compensation euh de dépenses de l'État
très clairement identifié donc j'aurais
j'aurais j'aurais aimé donc je je je
seraiis là-dessus très très engagé parce
que parce que je le redit la sécurité
sociale n'appartient pas à l'état je le
je voilà la sécurité sociale
n'appartient pas à l'état elle a voilà
donc c'est donc on doit on doit faire ça
sur euh
c'est là que je je mais du coup
peut-être parce que les sujets sur
lesquels on est convaincu c'est là
quelque fois qu'on est les moins
convaincants le moins
convaincant ce que vous dites monsieur
le sénateur jaumier sur la néonate et
l'espérance de vie moi je pense
aujourd'hui que
c'est enfin il y a sur la néonate il y a
il y a plein de facteurs il y a plein de
facteurs on peut identifier trois déjà
pour les les mettre de côté ils existent
euh on a des grossesses de primop
parturiantes plus tardives avec une
mortalité infantile plus forte continue
on a eu des progrès qui font que des
bébés qui n'auraient pas
survécu naissent mais ne survivent pas
dans les premiers mois et puis on a une
difficulté majeure dans les services de
néonatologie dans plein endroit mais une
fois que j'ai dit ça moi je pense que le
sujet comme sur l'espérance de vie c'est
à la fin un sujet d'inégalité sociale de
santé uniquement je enfin uniquement ou
en très grande partie oui la la
mortalité infantile n'est pas la même en
Scine Saint-Denis ou dans certaines dans
territoires ruraux que au cœur de Paris
donc il y a des inégalité sociale de
santé et donc c'est là que mon sujet de
prévention revient aussi c'est que je
pense quand j'étais directeur général de
la RS on avait un programme
euh qui s'appelait le programme reméi de
réduction des inégalité sociale sur la
néonate qui avait permis de faire
baisser une femme pardon monsieur oui
une femme
précaire c'est un risque sanitaire ce
point est évident mais il est pas
évident partout donc ça veut dire que
l'osto va devoir consacrer plus de fric
à sa prise en charge à son suivi donc
est-ce qu'on finance qu'ère la réforme
du financement les hôpitaux pour que
quand ils sont dans des territoires plus
fragiles ils puissent consacrer plus
d'argent à la prise en charge des plus
précaires c'est pour ça que je considère
que moi c'est ça le déterminant central
sur ça madame madame la la sénatrice
Brulin peut-être je je n'ai pas assez je
on l' pas assez dit formalisé je je
disais l'autre jour je suis encore dans
ma période d'essès ça fait 3 mois et et
6 jours que je suis ministre je je mais
je crois euh profondément je l'ai même
écrit à l'issue de de mon mandat de DG
gdrs je crois qu'on ne s'en sortira que
par la prévention que par la prévention
et pas et encore une fois avec ça va
trop vite de dire ainsi la prévention et
la santé publique et la prévention
primaire secondaire tertière quaternaire
les les les les les les sujets doivent
bouger donc oui vous avez raison nous av
nous n'avons pas écrit suffisamment
cette feuille de route je suis d'accord
avec vous je c'est d'ailleurs un de mes
objectifs extrêmement
extrêmement précis c'est d'écrire cette
feuille de route pour embarquer tout le
monde mais par exemple l'assurance
maladie aujourd'hui elle a fait un un
changement culturel extrêmement fort en
étant vous la vous avez auditionné le DG
je sais pas si vous en a parlé en étant
beaucoup plus acteur de la prévention en
réinventant certains pourront dire des
sujets sur lesquels elle était il y a 20
ans et auxquels elle a renoncé pour de
pour des raisons bonnes ou mauvaises ses
centres de soins et cetera et cetera de
vaccination voilà donc moi je suis
vraiment tout à fait convaincu que
aujourd'hui la dégradation de certains
de nos indicateurs elle est liée au fait
que le tout curatif qui était
notre notre ADN il est il est en bout de
course et puis par ailleurs il y a il y
a sans doute je vais pas voilà des
sujets de de dégradation de l'offre même
curative dans certains endroits je le
mais pour moi le fait de structure c'est
qu'on on on est toujours dans notre
culture en retard sur la sur la prise en
compte de la de la prévention sur le le
la
Bernard monsieur jaumier vous avez
raison c'est pourquoi mon objectif c'est
que les trois blocs qu'on a évoqué pour
la financement de l'hôpital mais
j'arrive aux mêmes trois blocs dans le
financement du médecin c'est c'est mon
objectif alors peut-être fantasmer pour
avoir un jardin à la française mais je
pense que c'est le même sujet il y a de
l'acte il y a des dispositifs de santé
publique la prise en charge et il y a
des et il y a des prises en charge de
patients plus lourds et cetera donc on
va mon objectif c'est d'avoir de
paralléliser les deux types de
financement al à l'Ostau truc vous
retrouverez ce point dans la lettre dans
la lettre de cadrage je suis après
résolument convaincu mais ça renvoie à à
une question de la céentrice guidaise
que tout notre système ne pivotera que
si on met les moyens sur la santé de
l'enfant on aura dans quelques semaines
la présentation il y a eu un gros
travail qui a été fait par la professeur
gralegouen avec Adrien taqué ils ont
présenté 220 propositions c'est beaucoup
donc donc on a on en retient en priorité
non parce que en fait quand vous faites
propositions vous offrez sur un plateau
au ministère le fait de dire en fait il
y en avait tellement qu'on sait pas très
bien vous dire où on en est donc moi je
préfère en avoir quelques-unes sur
lesquels je puisse rendre des comptes
euh pour dire les choses et oui vous
avez raison on a le truc 1000 jours que
vous n'avez pas évoqué mais a a fait
progresser mais je pense qu'on on se
planterait avec cette barrière à 7 ans à
1000 jours ou à 7 ans parce qu'il y a
encore des troubles qu'on peut détecter
plus tard qu'on doit pouvoir rembourser
sans sans recours complémentaire et euh
c'est et ce qui se passe et ce qu'on a
vécu en quelques années sur les TND mon
monre à quel point typiquement je veux
dire on est en capacité aujourd'hui si
on repère plutôt donc si on a ce
dispositif de repérage et de prévention
de de de faire reculer l'autisme comme
comme comme comme jamais on l'a entre
les mains voilà donc je je suis d'accord
avec vous les les barrières d'âge les
les flutes les frontières d'âge ne se me
Satis font pas à ce stade voilà je vais
pas échapper à la question de Bernard
sur laame
euh je pense que l'aide médicale d'État
euh est un dispositif indispensable que
c'est un dispositif de santé publique de
santé publique les pays qui ont basculé
dans le système que la majorité du Sénat
a adopté dans euh la la loi immigration
euh sur l'aide médicale d'urgence après
sans forcément le défi finir très
précisément je le dis ici pour moi euh
est un dispositif qui va conduire à deux
choses et et c'est ma crainte c'est la
première c'est le déversement sur
l'hôpital de tous les soins urgents et
donc à partir de là d'une certaine
manière c'est jeter un voile pudique sur
le coût de tout ça parce que ça sera
noyé dans les dépenses hospitalière
laame c'est aujourd'hui une des dépenses
qui est la suivie de plus près parce
qu'en fait comme c'est payé par l'État
ben on le on le suit et donc moi je
pense qu'aucun médecin ne refusera de
soigner quelqu'un parce que il est
arrivé aux urgence parce qu'il est pas
avec son ame ou son Amu et le deuxième
sujet qui est pour moi de santé publique
majeur c'est que le but de la me euh de
la prise en charge c'est que on
intervienne avant que la situation soit
devenue trop grave et donc notamment sur
toutes les euh les pathologies
infectieuse il est évident que si la
médecine de ville n'est plus n'est plus
là ACC cours sur tuberculose hépatite et
cetera on va diffuser des pathologies
l'Espagne qui a tenté cette réforme est
revenue en arrière et c'est vrai que je
m'arrête là sur les comparaisons parce
qu'en fait beaucoup de pays noi ça dans
la dépense hospitalière donc à titre le
le ministre de la Santé à qui vous poser
la question à cette à cette opposition
il y a une mission qui a été confiée euh
par par Gérald armanin et moi à Patrick
stéphanini et à Claude Évin qui
travaillent et qui ont sont déjà en
immersion profonde sur ce sujet euh moi
il y a des sujets je je le dis pardon
quand ça coûte un milliard et quelques
d'euros à la nation je vais pas dire il
est interdit de regarder c'est normal de
regarder si le dispositif voilà je pense
par exemple je vous dis qu'il y a une
certaine peut-être qu'il y a des choses
où qu'on pourrait mettre sous-entente
près sur certaines opérations j'en sais
rien je j'ouvre ça j'en sais rien mais
par ailleurs je voudrais tuer une partie
des fantasmes il y a eu l'an dernier les
oreilles décollées qui dont tout le
monde nous parle il y a eu ça a coûté
6000 € 6000 € en tout 35 opérations ce
qui doit correspondre si mes calculs
sont bons à 70 oreilles et quand on
parle d'oreilles décollées je je quand
on parle d'oreilles
décollées on parle de de de de situation
dans lesquels aujourd'hui en France il y
a des organisations humanitaires qui
envoient des chirurgiens pour opérer à
l'étranger pour réparer ces ces
diffformité on parle pas d'un soin de
confort donc ma position euh elle est
simple dès lors que le Parlement euh
souhaite qu'on regarde un dispositif on
peut le challenger à nouveau il a été
challengé en 2019 euh par Édouard
Philippe le panier de soins a été réduit
qu'on le regarde à nouveau il y a moi je
n'ai absolument aucun aucun
sujet là-dessus mais je vous dis je je
pense que c'est d'abord un dispositif de
santé publique je je je finis parce que
là sinon je vais me faire euh dégommer
euh le cocouning des médecins de que je
suis heureux que cette parole vienne de
la sénatrice brullin je vous voulez donc
que je cocoune les médecins généraliste
je libéraux donc je je m'en je m'en
réjouis en fait encore une fois je l'ai
dit on aura le débat sur l'article 27 il
y a pas de doute euh
euh et je pense que ça répond à une
partie de votre question suivante ce
débat sur l'article 27 on l'a pas eu à
l'Assemblée on l'a pas eu à l'Assemblée
ils l'ont eu en partie en commission on
l'a pas eu à l'Assemblée moi je souhaite
l'avoir je vous dis très franchement
cette mesure qui est une mesure signale
plus qu'une mesure voilà est-ce que moi
c'est pas tellement en fait c'est pas
tellement vis-à-vis des médecins mon
sujet c'est vis-à-vis de de y compris de
sembler faire porter euh symboliquement
et politiquement la responsabilité de
l'explosion des zigis sur le patient ça
me ça me je suis pas sûr que ce soit
voilà donc on aura le débat je vous ai
dit je suis ouvert sur ce sur ce débat
euh il y a un mot qui n'a pas été
prononcé ici donc comme moi je suis un
gentil garçon je vais le prononcer c'est
le mot inflation euh j'ai bien écouté
donc ça ne s pas décl clanché je pense
que dans les critiques qui ont été
émises sur le PLFSS il y en a beaucoup
qui sont qui ont été faites par toutes
les fédérations sur le fait qu'il y a
pas de compensation 23 suffisante de
l'inflation je le dis ici
[Musique]
euh ce sujet moi je vais pas laisser je
ne vais pas le gouvernement ne va pas
laisser les hôpitaux publics ou privés
basculer dans le rouge parce que il y
aurait juste sur le terrain de
l'inflation donc on fera on devra
intervenir la question c'est qu'à la
l'heure où on se parle c'est-à-dire le
26 octobre je ne sais pas où on atterrit
en terme de justement ce que ce
qu'évoquait Corine Amber sur ONDAM sous
Onam sur le niveau de consommation
d'exécution de sous-exécution donc on
fera un point à la fin de l'année mais
je pense qu'on devra intervenir en
matière d'inflation dans une circulaire
tarifaire tarifaire nouvelle les
franchises médicales madame la Catrice
je vais pas je vais là non plus pas
tenter d'échapper à votre question euh
aujourd'hui et Jérôme Gedge hier avec
Cyril Isac cibil ont fait leur visite à
la Direction de la Sécurité sociale donc
ils ont constaté comme je leur avais dit
que nous avons travaillé à ce sujet nous
avons travaillé à ce sujet dans des
conditions très précises effectivement
euh la question de des franchises
médicales et des de deuxè mot chaque
fois et des participations forfaitaires
avec le maintien des deux plafonds à 50
€ avec le maintien des de plafond à 50 €
c'est-à-dire le maintien
essentiel pour les personnes an
Al qui sont celles qui tamponnent si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi les plafonds donc
cette mesure elle a été
instruite c'est effectivement une mesure
réglementaire c'est une mesure
réglementaire qui a un chemin de de de
comment on dit de décidément aujourd'hui
j'ai un problème de de TND quoi de
de de mise en œuvre non et de de il y a
toute une série de consultations à
mettre en œuvre il y a 4 mois de
consultation à mettre en œuvre devant un
tas de d'organismes et pour être très
clair je le dis très
simplement aujourd'hui moi je considère
et le président de la République et la
premierre ministre considère que ce
sujet
il on a on l' instruit on est prêt à le
il peut être mise en œuvre moi je l'ai
dit dès que j'ai été nommé j'ai jamais
caché ça mais je pense que ça on ne peut
pas le faire sans être allé au bout y
compris de l'examen des débats sur le
PLF et dans une période où les Français
ont le sentiment que enfin c'est pas
plus que le sentiment c'est où la
pression sur le pouvoir d'achat elle est
telle que si à la fin il est considéré
que c'était qu'une mesure pour faire les
poches des gens on aurait
euh voilà donc moi j'assume de dire
cette mesure elle elle a elle a de toute
façon 4 mois pour être mise en œuvre on
l'a expertisé elle est prête mais on
fera
une la décision elle sera prise à
l'issue des débats parlementaire et
effectivement oui c'est un c'est une
responsabilité du du du pouvoir du
pouvoir règlementaire
euh Madame La la la je crois sur Madame
Catrice pumirol que j'ai répondu un peu
sur les les
innovations
euh et
comment et sur la transparence pr si si
si si j'arrive non non j'arrive j'arrive
parce que j'ai la pression du président
physiquement à mes côtés qui me stresse
sur la transparence des prix
euh comment dire oui vous avez raison il
y a pas de transparence des prix même y
compris quelquefois parce que le le le
le le mais le seul le point que je
voulais les
soulev c'est que évidemment y compris
même si c'est étrange une partie des
industriels vous disent si vous mettez
trop de pression sur le prix on ne met
pas ce médicament sur le marché français
enfin vous savez et c'est du ça je vous
laisse la responsabilité de ce terme que
il me semble assez juste et donc oui on
a cette dimension là on a aussi la
dimension
réindustrialisation notamment sur les mé
médicament critique et donc c'est vrai
que on poursuit simultanément plusieurs
objectifs dans lequel le prix n'est pas
le la seule variable de discussion avec
avec les laboratoires après c'est ce que
j'ai voulu dire tout à l'heure en
introduction à la question de la
rapporteur
ber c'est que je pense ou pardon
rapporteur général douanau je pense que
notre système de fixation du prix
aujourd'hui il y a plus que trois
personnes qui comprennent comment ça
marche au monde quoi donc euh donc
euh on doit le on doit le on doit le
remettre au propre et se dire en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on cherche simultanément et
au moins que les objectifs soient
démocratiquement partagés sur ATMP je
sais je sais pas par je sais je ne je ne
sais pas c'est la partie du soft du
PLFSS ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
quand notamment dans la en travaillant
sur la réforme des retraites on avait
effectivement fait ce swap de taux sur
ATMP c'était euh avec l'idée que ça
n'était pas consommé et qu'il avait
voilà aujourd'hui euh je je me permets
si vous voulez bien dans l'après-midi
par le biais du président de vous faire
une réponse par mail parce que je ne je
ne suis pas capable de répondre et et je
je dis suffisamment de bêtises pour ne
pas quand je sais que j'en dis je
préfère me taire
voilà merci monsieur le ministre en tout
cas pour la pour la qualité de vos
réponses voilà donc la suite maintenant
dans
l'hémicycleci en commission en premier
temps puis dans l'hémicycle voilà je
rappelle juste à nos collègues he que
mardi prochain nous avons trois
auditions dans la journée hein donc
14h30 15h30 et 17h comment pas en
vacances non voilà merci
beaucoup